PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE IN RESPONSE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
WEBSITE FOR OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME. YOU
WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU WILL
BE READY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON A REPEAT THAT YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES WANTS TO
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY.
ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE WILL ONLY
BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY. MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. ON
THE MEASURES. IT IS IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
BE MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
HERE AND ANY INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS.
OR TECHNOLOGIES SO PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. WE HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE TWO
MEASURES PROPOSED FOR CONSENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO. A. B.
EIGHT THREE ZERO AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE A. B. ONE ONE ZERO
TWO. WE WILL BE OPERATING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY UNTIL SOME
OF OUR MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO GET
TO THE CHAMBER. AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BE
PREPARED TO TAKE VOTES ON
MEASURES. WE WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER WELCOME
SIR YOU HAVE ONE BILL TO
PRESENT TODAY IT IS A. B. THREE
FIVE NINE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
VERSUS. EIGHTY THREE FIVE NINE
WELL DRESSED CALIFORNIANS
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES PRACTICING CALIFORNIA
ALLEGEDLY INCREASED ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND IMPROVE
PATIENT HEALTH OUTCOMES.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE ALLOWS OUT OF
STATE DOCTORS OF OSTEOPATHY TO
RECEIVE A LICENSE TO PRACTICE
MEDICINE IN CALIFORNIA.
PROVIDED THEY HOLD UNDER STRICT
IT AND UNLIMITED LICENSE IN
GOOD STANDING IN ANOTHER STATE
CONVERSELY IN THESE NOT PROVIDE
THE SAME RECIPROCITY. IN FACT
THE BEST PROFESSIONS CODE
CONTAINS LANGUAGE THAT
INDICATES THAT ANY DISPARITIES
BETWEEN THE TREATMENT OF INDIES
AND DEAL WITH IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. EIGHTY THREE FIVE
NINE WOULD MODIFY THE EXISTING
RECIPROCITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
OUT OF STATE INDIES MAKING THEM
CONSISTENT WITH THE RECIPROCITY
STATUTES THAT I REPLY TO OTHER
INDEPENDENT. OUT OF STATE
HEALTH CARE PRACTITIONERS LIKE
DOCTORS ARE ALL TOO PATH THESE.
SPECIFICALLY THEBILL OUT
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE LICENSED IN
ANOTHER STATE BUT PAST STEP
THREE THE UNITED STATES MEDICAL
LIFE EXAM ON THEIR FIFTH OR
SIXTH TRY TO SEE THE LICENSE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL TO BRING A NUMBER OF
PHYSICIANS WHO DESIRE TO
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
CAN'T UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW. THE SECOND PART OF THE
BILL RESPECTED MEDICAL
EDUCATION CURRICULUM TO ENSURE
THAT POSITIONS ARE EDUCATED
ABOUT THE LATEST MEDICAL
PRACTICE TECHNIQUES. THESE
COURSES THE ONLY COST 230% OF
THE POSITIONS REQUIRED CMT. BY
WITNESSES MISS HITS PLUS
CONSPECIFIC TYPES OF C. N. B.
C. B. THREE FIVE NINE THE HELP
ADDRESS OUR PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE
OR REQUIRING THESE NEW
POSITIONS TO BE QUALIFIED. TO
HAVE PASSED ALL STANDARDIZED
TEST. A FULLY LICENSED AND IN
GOOD STANDING IN ANOTHER STATE.
THE CME CREDIT EXPANSION WILL-
MEDIC- PRACTICES TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND SAFE. WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT DURING THIS
CHALLENGING TIME. I HAVE OFTEN
BEEN TO SOME OF THE BOARD
CONCERN. ONE THING YOU CONSULT
SIR MASON FOR OF OUR- WITH THIS
BILL. THERE WERE TWENTY TWO
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORTING THE
BILL. THIS BILL IS ENJOY
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE. WITH THEIR WITNESSES DR
ARORA ASSISTANT CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT THE USC OF
MEDICINE AND JULIANA HENCE. THE
MAZE DIRECTOR OF CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION. WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. MR CHAIRMAN AND
IF THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DR LAURA I'M ALSO IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE DOESN'T ONLY DOCTOR
WITH YOUR IDEA DOCTOR WITH YOU
HOLD UP A SECOND WE CANNOT HEAR
YOU SO WE WILL ADJUST TO. MAKE
AN ADJUSTMENT HERE. IS IT CAN
YOU HEAR ME NOW MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE- BETTER PLEASE
SPEAK UP THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM DOCTOR
AURORA I'M ALSO IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE AS AN OBGYN FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA. THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS IN CALIFORNIA AND
EXPECTED TO ACCENTUATE FURTHER
BECAUSE OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT. AND EXPANSION TO EVENTUAL
UNIVERSALLY CARE. I HAVE
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND THE
SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS IN OUR STATE AS I
HAVE TRIED TO RECRUIT POSITIONS
FOR MY PRACTICE. IT HAS BEEN
THE SAME DILEMMA TRYING TO ADD
POSITIONS TO THE MATERNITY
DEPARTMENT AT MY LOCAL
HOSPITAL. THE SOLE INTENT AND
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
FOR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. ONLY
ALLOWS FULLY QUALIFIED AND
TRAINED PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE
PASSED ALL THE REQUIRED TESTS
AND ARE LICENSED IN ANOTHER
STATE IN GOOD STANDING. TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR LICENSURE IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY STILL HAVE TO
FULFILL ALL THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REMOVES THE
ARBITRARY LMIT THE POTENTIAL.
FOR PASSAGE OF USMLE STEP THREE
EXAMS FOR LICENSURE. DOCTORS OF
OSTEOPATHY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
THE SAME LIMIT. THE EXISTING
ALTERNATE PATHWAYS DO NOT
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL SUB GROUP
OF PHYSICIANS. I HAVE LEARNED
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN TEACHING
RESIDENTS AT USC AND IN MY
INTERACTION WITH OTHER
POSITIONS THAT THERE IS NO GOOD
CORRELATION BETWEEN
STANDARDIZED TEST TAKING AND
BEING A GOOD POSITION SOME
PHYSICIANS ARE NOT GOOD ****
BECAUSE OF VARIOUS REASONS BUT
THEY CAN BE THE MOST EMPATHETIC
AND KIND POSITIONS AND THE MOST
SKILLFUL SURGEONS. TO SUMMARIZE
THIS BILL POTENTIALLY ADDS
HUNDREDS TO THE POSITION PRONE
TO RENDER MUCH NEEDED CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS EVERY
POSITION EQUALS ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND PATIENT VISITS PER
YEAR.AND THE BILL HAS NO
DOWNSIDE WHATSOEVER. I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
HEALTH CARE BILL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING KAREN NUMBERS IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE HERE I'M GOING
ON AHEAD THE DIRECTOR OF
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION AT
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. THE M. A. IS THE
EIGHTEENTH YOU NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE CREDITOR FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
CREDIT OVER TWO HUNDRED
CONTINUING MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROVIDERS NOT ONLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT ALSO IN ALASKA
AND NEVADA AND OREGON. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ORGANIZATIONS
ACCREDITED BY CMA PROVIDED OVER
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND HOURS OF.
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
POSITION LEARNER. THIS IS
RELYING ON A CREDIT IF YOU NEED
HELP AND DRIVE IMPROVEMENTS IN
PRACTICE AND OPTIMIZE THE CARE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS THE FUSION.
A KEY COMPONENT OF ACCREDITED
ME AT THE PRESENT POSITIONS
WITH COMMERCIALLY UNBIASED
INDEPENDENT OBJECTIVE AND
EVIDENCE BASED INFORMATION AND
ALL ACTIVITIES. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT RESTRICT ACTIVITIES FROM
INCLUDING BUSINESS ASPECTS OF
MEDICINE WHICH PUTS US OUT OF
ALIGNMENT WITH THE ARMY
NATIONALLY. AND IT MEANS THAT
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PROVISIONS IN
CALIFORNIA COULD NOT EARN THE
ARMY FOR EDUCATION ON
TRANSITIONING HOW HELP.
BASICALLY RE OPENING THEIR
PRACTICES ADJUSTING CLINICAL
WORKFLOWS TO MAXIMIZE STAFF AND
PATIENT SAFETY FILE THEIR
COLLEAGUES IN EVERY OTHER STATE
WERE ABLE. TO EARN A NEED FOR
THAT SAME EDUCATION. EIGHTY
THREE FIVE. WE'LL HELP. FEDERAL
WITH ME NOT. AND ALLOW FOR THE
CONCERN ANY CREDIT FOR
EDUCATION NOT BETTER SERVE
THEIR PATIENTS AND THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. ROSS ROSS
HERE MELINDA'S ARCHULETA.
PARTULIDAE HERE BEAT. BECKER
DAUGHTER. DOT HERE EIGHT MEN.
EIGHT MEN HERE HER TADO HER
TADO HERE JONES. JONES HERE
LEAVE THAT MAN. MAIN HERE
NEWMAN A TERRIBLE ODOR HAN. HE
CAN HEAR WE HAVE A CORE OF NOW
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY WAS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. THREE FIVE
NINE. I SEE NO WITNESSES THERE
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SEVICE AND
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THEIR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIVE NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR TO- TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR A. B. THREE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
KATIE OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND THEN
PLACE IT BACK IN THE QUEUE IN
FOR- OUT FIRST. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF BABY THREE FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO WE'LL BEGIN TODAY WITH
WIND THIRTY SEVEN. ONE MOMENT
THIRTY SEVEN. YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND MAKE IT.
I'M DR MANMOHAN MAY AFFECT THE
THING- IN APPLE VALLEY AND I.
A. THE PRESIDENT OVER QUITE
MEDICAL GROUP. WHEN I WAS THERE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE N. WORD IN
THE MEDICAL SOCIETY ANYONE I AM
THE ONE OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AT LOCAL HOSPITALS.
AND I NEED TO ADD TO THE- BED
BATH TO CANCEL I SPORT A
REPRIEVE FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. NIKOLAI FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RECTANGLES
ON BEHALF OF CHOICE MEDICAL
GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE FIVE NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO PLEASE CALL AT.
HI MY NAME IS DR SAMIR CHOPRA
UROLOGIC SURGEON FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA
AND  AM IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE FIVE NINE. NINE THE
FAMILY MEMBER COOPER THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU HELLO FIND OUT THE
LOCATION. PEDIATRICIAN PRIVATE
PRACTICE FOR THE PAST TWENTY
FOUR YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
APPLICATION BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL. SPEAKING OF
AN INDIVIDUAL IT'S BEEN. THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. AS A FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY THREE FIVE
NINE. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE. SEEING NONE LET'S
CHECK WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIVE NINE. I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES. THAT'SMOVED
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR ONCEAGAIN IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIVE NINE WILL PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR- DISH
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
EIGHTY THREE FIVE NINE. S. ONE
FILED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. ONE MOMENT WE HAVE
ONE QUEUING UP. EVERYBODY ELSE
GOING AT ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ARE WE WILL GO TO LIKE
FIFTY TO YOUR OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS ERIN BONE WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA HAS
INDICATED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
BOARD IS REGRETTABLY OPPOSED TO
LISTEN UNTIL THREE FIFTY NINE.
ARCHITECTING COMPONENT OF THE
BILL CURRENT LAW PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL PATHWAYS TO
LICENSURE INCLUDING THE
APPLICANTS WHO REQUIRED MORE
THAN FOUR TIMES TO PASS THE
UNITED STATES MEDICAL LICENSING
EXAMINATION FOR US AND THE
ONLY. OTHER PATHWAYS ARE
FREQUENTLY USED AS ONE HUNDRED
EVERY SIX LICENSES ISSUED EACH
YEAR GOES TO ONE OF THESE
APPLICANTS CURRENTLY LICENSED
IN ANOTHER STATE. AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS THIS PORTION OF
THE BILL IS CONTRARY TO THE
NATIONAL POLICY ON THE NUMBER
OF ALLOWED ATTEMPTS TO PASS THE
EXAM. AS OF THIS MONTH UNDER U.
S. GENERALLY RULES A FIRING
POSITIONS ARE NOW LIMITED TO
FOUR ATTEMPTS TO PASS THE EXAM.
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW. GIVEN
THIS POLICY IN A SIGNIFICANT
VOLUME OF OUT OF STATE
POSITIONS SUCCESSFULLY OBTAINED
A LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
BENEFIT OF THIS BILL. TO
CONSUMERS IT'S UNCLEAR TO THE
BOARD. WHAT THE BOARD CONSIDER
THIS BILL DURING THE MOST READ
MEETING OUR MEMBERS WERE
CONCERNED BY THE LACK OF
EVIDENCE PRESENTED BY THE
SPONSORS ON THE BILL'S IMPACT
TO CONSUMERS. IT IS UNKNOWN TO
THE BOARD HOW MANY ARTISTIC
POSITIONS WHO DESIRE TO
PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. ARE
UNABLE TO MEET THE DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS TO LICENSURE AVAILABLE
TODAY THE CURRENT LAW. WITHOUT
SUCH EVIDENCE THE BOARD WAS
UNABLE TO EVALUATE HOW MANY CAN
HELP CONSUMERS MAY BE IMPACTED
BY THIS PROVISION OF THE BILL.
WITH REGARD TO THE CONTINUING
MEDICAL EDUCATION PORTION I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
SPONSORS FOR COLLABORATING ON
ARTISAN AND IS DESCRIBED IN THE
ANALYSIS. THAT CLARIFIES THE
30% LIMITATION. HOWEVER I MUST
NOTE THAT THE BOARD HAS NOT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONSIDER
THIS LANGUAGE. AT THE LIMIT
WHAT WAS PUT IN THE- AFTER THE
BOARD ITS- LAW REQUIRES. SCHOOL
FOR. DIRECTLY CARE. AND THAT IS
CONNECTED TO THE- OF A MAN
LICENSE WHICH IS DIAGNOSE AND
TREAT. FURTHER LOT OF PROHIBIT
PHYSICIAN FROM TO BUSINESS. IF
THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO. BUT
APPROPRIATELY THOSE COURSES TO
NOT COUNT TOWARDS. WORK AT
THOSE COURSES ARE NOT RELATED
TO THE SKILL AND KNOWLEDGE USED
BY PHYSICIANS TO PROVIDE CARE
TO THEIR PATIENTS. CONCERNS
WITH EIGHTY THREE FIFTY NINE
THE POOR RECORD REQUEST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
AND AS A REMINDER TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE FIVE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. MR SURE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU LET'S NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
CALLING CITY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS. SIR BEN I THANK
YOU SO MUCH ACTUALLY I DO HAVE
A QUESTION OF THE MEMBER FOR
THE MEDICAL BOARD IS. THAT THE
APPROPRIATE. CERTAINLY IF TE
MEDICAL BOARD REPRESENTATIVE IS
STILL ON THE LINE. FIX YOUR
QUESTION DOCTRINE YEAH ACTUALLY
IT'S- TWO PARTS- SO FIRST OF
ALL- REGARDING TESTIMONY. ON
THIS ON THE CME- I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE BOARD'S POSITION
ABOUT. THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE
INTO SOMEONE WHO IS ON THIS
COMMITTEE IS FREQUENTLY TALKED
TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEING SURE WE HAVE GOOD C. M.
E. BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
TALK CLARIFIED WHAT'S THE BOARD
TO PETITION- FOR EXAMPLE- YOU
KNOW WHAT WE TALK ABOUT SYSTEMS
BASED PRACTICE THAT'S WHAT
ACTUALLY COMPETENCIES IN THE
ACGME- THAT THEY'VE IDENTIFIED
THE PHYSICIANS THAT HAVE. THOSE
INCLUDE THINGS SUCH AS BEING
YELP INSURING THAT YOU ORGANIZE
YOUR PRACTICE IN A WAY THAT-
ENGENDER STATION SAFETY FOR
EXAMPLE THE RESPONSE THE
COVETED- THOSE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES WITH THAT- EIGHT IS
THAT NOT VIEWED BY THE MEDICAL
BOARD OUR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
TYPE EFFORTS. WHICH AGAIN TALKS
ABOUT PROCESS SEES THAT HAPPEN
IN THE PRACTICE IS THAT NOT
INTERPRETED BY THE MEDICAL
BOARD IS- THAT IS BEING-
FITTING- THIS IS QUALIFYING FOR
CME SO THAT'S QUESTION NUMBER
ONE. AND THEN I GUESS THE
SECOND QUESTION IS THAT I KNOW
IN THE ANALYSIS AND THE
TESTIMONY THEY SAID THAT THERE
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS-
FOR A PHYSICIAN WHO. IS
QUALIFIED TO PRACTICE IN
ANOTHER STATE SO WE HAVE- WHO
WISHES TO COME TO CALIFORNIA
WHO MAY NOT HAVE ACTUALLY- I
GUESS PAST THE USMLE AND WITHIN
THE FIRST. FOUR- FOR. FOUR
TIMES AFTER- IT IS CAN CAN YOU
GIVE ME MORE OF A DESCRIPTION
OF WHAT THAT PATHWAY THEN
ENTAILS- THAT TO ALLOW SOMEONE
TO USE TO STILL BE ABLE TO
PRACTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY SHOW THEY'VE BEEN
AT A PRACTICE SAFELY IN ANOTHER
STATE SO WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS
THOSE TWO ISSUES THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO ME THANK YOU. IS THE
MEDICAL REPORT REPRESENTATIVE
STILL ON THE LINE. NOW DOCTOR
PAN THAT MAY BE A RHETORICAL
QUESTION MAYBE YOU CAN ANSWER
IT. OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I CAN
CERTAINLY DON'T SPEAK FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD THAT I'VE BEEN
HELPFUL TO HEAR FROM THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND THOSE THINGS
I AM ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
ASTONISHED THAT- THE
INTERPRETATION- IT'S ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT WITHIN THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION SYSTEM BASED
PRACTICE IS ONE OF THE
COMPETENCIES WE ACTUALLY TRAIN
POSITIONS FOR- SO I APPRECIATE
THAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO FIX
THIS ISSUE I DO WONDER IF. THE
WAY THE MEDICAL BOARD IS
INTERPRETED SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES IS NOT QUALIFYING
FOR CME MAY NOT HAVE. BEEN ABLE
TO NARROW BUT AGAIN IT'S THEIR
JUDGMENT I APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT IN THIS BILL AND-
CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW THE CODE
SECTIONS ARE NICE- AND ANALYSIS
BUT DIDN'T REALLY DESCRIBE WHAT
SOMEONE HAVE TO GO THROUGH SO-
SO AGAIN APPRECIATE THAT- WE'RE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PHYSICIANS
WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PRACTICE
IN GOOD STANDING IN OTHER
STATES. AND I THINK HAVING SOME
CLARITY AS TO WHAT THOSE
ALTERNATE PATHWAYS WERE FROM
THE BOARD WITHIN HELPFUL TO
KNOW WHAT WHAT THAT INVOLVED
BUT I GUESS WE DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT- I GUESS I'LL
HAVE TO DO IS HAVE TO GO WITH
THIS BUILDING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR PLAN FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND YOUR COMMENTS
CALLINGS ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
ARCH ALETTA. SOME REMEMBER
COOPER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR WE HAVE A MOTION ON
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIVE NINE-
SEMI MEMBER COOPER AS- ACCEPTED
AMENDMENTS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
ONE A. B. THREE FIVE NINE DO
YOU PROCESS A MINUTE BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN PLEASE HAVE
YOUR MICROPHONE ON AND SPEAK
YOUR VOTE INTO THE MICROPHONE
THAT'S HELPFUL. RALPH HI RALPH
HI MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA BY OUR
CHILL OUT I'D BE TH. BACKER BY.
BECKER I'D DODD I THOUGHT I A
MAN HI. HEY MAN HI HER TADO.
JONES JONES I LEAVE A- MAN HI
MAN HI NIMIN. THAT SHOW A BOGUS
AT SHOWBOAT IPN HI CAN I. BILL
HAS NINE VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS THANK YOU
SIR. LET'S MOVE TO- ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN DOCTOR WOULD AT US MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU WERE NOT
GOING TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIVE TO SIX. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX IS A RATHER
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILLET
ACCOMPLISHES TWO THINGS FIRST
OKAY TO CODIFIES CURRENT
AUTHORIZATION GRANTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THAT ALLOWS DENTISTS AND
PODIATRISTS PODIATRIST TO
INITIATE AND ADMINISTER
VACCINES APPROVED BY THE FDA
FOR COVERT NINETEEN. UNDER THIS
BILL THE ADDITIONAL VACCINES TO
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
DENTISTS AND PODIATRISTS HIS
CONDITION ON THE SAME TRAINING
AND RECORD KEEPING REQUIREMENTS
THE PHARMACISTS ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE IN ORDER
TO ADMINISTER VACCINES.
ADDITIONALLY AB FIVE TWENTY SIX
WOULD INCLUDE THE FLU SHOT
WHICH IS ANOTHER VACCINE
PHARMACIST MADE MINISTER FOR
WHICH EXPANDED ACCESS IS OF
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. IN TWENTY TEN I
AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN TEN A
BILL THAT AUTHORIZES
PHARMACISTS TO INDEPENDENTLY
INITIATED. INFLUENZA VACCINES
APPROVED OR AUTHORIZED BY THE
FDA. THIS BILL MAHER IS THAT
BILL BY ALLOWING APPROPRIATELY
TRAINED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES AND TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO CODE NINETEEN THE
IMMUNIZATIONS. OFFERING
VACCINES AT EVERY ENTRY POINT
IN THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WILL
EASE VACCINE HESITANCY OF
SAFETY CONCERNS AND TURN
IMMUNIZATION INTO A CONCERTED
COORDINATED HEALTH CARE EFFORT.
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL
ALIGNS CALIFORNIA LABORATORY
REGISTRATION STATUTE WITH
FEDERAL LAW SO THE DENTIST CAN
OBTAIN THE APPROPRIATE STATE
REGISTRATION ALONG SIDE THEIR
FEDERAL LICENSURE IN ORDER TO
CONDUCT SIMPLE RELIABLE WAY TO
TEST THAT ARE WITHIN THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE. DESERT
CURRENTLY NOT ABLE TO REGISTER
AS LABORATORY DIRECTOR TO
OVERSEE WEIGHT TEST UNDER
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW. TO
PERFORM QUOTE UNQUOTE WAVES
TEST DENNIS IN CALIFORNIA-
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN. BOTH
FEDERAL CLIA CERTIFICATES OF
WAIVER THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES AS WELL
AS STATE REGISTRATION THROUGH
THE CD PH IS LAB. FIELD
SERVICES DISCONNECT HEY THE
FEDERAL SORT OF- THEY'RE NOT
KERR HELD TO. A D. FEEL
REGISTRATION BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT ON THE LIST OF PROVIDERS
WHO MAY REGISTER AS A LAB
DIRECTOR. THERE ARE NO FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS OR QUALIFICATIONS
FOR THAT RECORD LAB DIRECTORS
THAT HAVE CERTIFICATES OF
WAIVERS. DOES HAVE A QUICKLY
TRAIN TO OTHER PROVIDERS WHO
MAY REGISTER AS A LAB DIRECTOR
WAS C. DPH. AND SHOULD BE ABLE
TO ACQUIRE THE STATE LAB LAB
DIRECTOR STATUS IN ORDER TO
CONDUCT WAVE TESTS THAT ARE
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
EXAMPLE OF THE WAY THE TEST
WOULD BE A RAPID POINT OF CARE
TEST FOR COOK NINETEEN THAT IS
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE AND READILY
AVAILABLE SO DENNIS MAY BE ABLE
TO SCREEN ALL PATIENTS BEFORE
DENTAL TREATMENT. AND TO HELP
DIRECT A SYMPTOMATIC PATIENTS
TO APPROPRIATE CARE AND PROTECT
THE DELL TEAM FROM COVERT
NINETEEN EXPOSURE. BY TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX AND RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THE
STORY MY GROUP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK.
YOU WITH THIS PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SORRY I'M A CREW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND MEMBER
DENNIS WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR ANY FIVE TWENTY SIX AM
THANK DR WARD FOR INTRODUCING
IT. JENNIFER PODIATRISTS
PHARMACISTS AND OTHER
NONTRADITIONAL VACCINATORS
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THEIR
HEALTHCARE COLLEAGUES HAVE
SHOWN. THAT WE CAN- TOGETHER
HAVE POSITIVELY INCREASE OUR
STATE VACCINATION RIGHT.
CODIFYING ADMINISTRATION OF
CORRECTLY AND WILL ENSURE THAT
THE STATE CONTINUES OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORTS ON COPING
IMMUNIZATION PARTICULARLY IF
THERE ARE ANY POTENTIAL
BOOSTERS IN THE FUTURE. AND
INCREASE PUBLIC ACCESS TO FLU
SHOT. DR WOULD HAVE COVERED
MOST EVERYTHING THAT I WOULD
SAY THAT I AM HERE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELLO SIR
FROM ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLERY. WE HAVE ONE SIR
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. RYAN
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY AND
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE LET'S
CHECK ROOM ONE TWELVE FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE TO SIX. SAYING NOT ON MY
COMPUTER SCREEN LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OF THIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TO SIX. WE'LL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR. AS HE SET
OUT T SHOW SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
FIVE TO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THIS TIME WHEN
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE TWENTY SIX.
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH LINE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE YOU
NEEDED FIFTY TWO. WELL AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO OR TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY FIVE TO
SIX. AND NOBODY ELSE IS DOING
UP AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR.
THANK MODERATOR WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR
MANY OPPOSITION FIRST WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE LET'S CHECK
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
TO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TO SIX I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR MISS
MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE TWENTY SIX WILL PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR THERE ARE NO LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
LET'S BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE CHAMBERS AND MY COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NONE SO MEMBER
WOULD WOULD LIKE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL. THE DOCTOR PENDEK
PAN MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR PAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE TO SIXTY
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RALPH HI RALPH HI MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA IV. BECKER
BACKER I'D DODD HI DONNA HI
AIKMAN HI HEY MAN I HEARD TANTO
ON HER TADO I'D JONES. JONES II
LLEVA. MAN MAN I KNEW MAN ABOUT OKAY HI A SHOW
ABOUT- GUY HAN HI CAN I- HAS
TEN VOTES WILL HOLD THE MATTER
OVER MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. LET'S
MOVE BACK TO. THE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. SIMPLY BILL. ONE ZERO
SIX FOUR SOME REMEMBER TOMORROW.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TEN SIXTY FOUR IS A TIMELY
RESPONSE TO OUR STATE'S ACTION
TO THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
AND THE WORK OF OUR PHARMACISTS
OPERATING ON THE FRONT LINES TO
MINISTER THEY WILL BACK SCENES
WHETHER IT'S AN INDEPENDENT
PHARMACISTS PER ONE FROM WHAT
WHEN A NATIONAL CHAINS
PHARMACISTS HAVE STEPPED UP TO
ASSIST IN CARING FOR
CALIFORNIANS LAST YEAR
LEGISLATION BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA ROSA AUTHORIZE
PHARMACISTS TO ADMINISTER THE
COVER NINETEEN VACCINE TO HELP
RELIEVE THE STRESSES ON OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. AND TO HELP
US REACH OUR COMMUNITY THIS
BILL WILL EXPAND PHARMACIST
VACCINATION THIRTY TWO ALL THAT
SEEMS APPROVED BY THE FDA FOR
CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
PHARMACIST MAY MINISTER
VACCINES LISTED UNDER ROUTINE
IMMUNIZATION SCHEDULES
RECOMMENDED BY THE BY THREE
COMMITTEE ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES. OR THERE'S A DELAY
BETWEEN WHEN A VACCINE IS
APPROVED BY THE FDA AND WHEN IT
IS REVIEWED BY THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THERE ARE STILL A
NUMBER OF VACCINATIONS APPROVED
BY THE FDA BUT NOT ON ROUTINE
IMMUNIZATION SCHEDULES I WANT
TO ASSURE THE COMMITTEE AND MY
COLLEAGUES THE A SET
RECOMMENDATION PROCESS WILL BE
FOLLOWED THE SIMPLE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO UTILIZE
COMMUNITY PHARMACIES TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE FOR
THOSE WHO NEED TAXATION
SERVICES. PHARMACISTS ARE
HIGHLY EDUCATED HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS WITH YEARS OF
EDUCATION EXPERIENCE TO EARN
THEIR DOCTOR PHARMACY NOT ONLY
ARE PHARMACIES AVAILABLE IN
INCREDIBLY CAPABLE BUT THEY ARE
TRUSTED MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
EDUCATION TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE MORE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE HEALTHCARE SERVICES
YOU MUST BETTER TILIZE
COMMUNITY PHARMACIES I'M JOINED
TODAY BY DR RAJINDER RUSSIAN
MEDIA AND MICHELLE RIVAS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION RESPECT AS PRIVATE.
THANK YOU SIR WITNESSES PLEASE
PROCEED. RESEARCHER AND MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
THE TOP. TO IT YOU TODAY. MY
NAME IS DR RUSSIAN MEDIA BYTES
PER. CRACKED TO PROVIDE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION.
PARTICIPANTS SAFELY PROVIDING
VACCINES SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN NINETY. OVER THE YEAR
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
GIVEN PHARMACIST INCREASING
AUTONOMY AND- INDEPENDENTLY
DETERMINED VACCINE. NEEDS AND
THEN ADMINISTER BASED ON THE
EDUCATION TRAINING AND PROVEN
EFFECTIVENESS IN VACCINATION
EFFORTS. ARE MRS UNDERGO THREE
TO FOUR YEARS OF PROFESSIONAL
GRADUATE LEVEL STUDY TO RECEIVE
A DOCTOR OF PHARMACY DEGREE. IN
ADDITION MOST GRADUATES
RECEIVED FORMAL TRAINING TO
SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE
VACCINE. WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR
OF THE PHARMACY EDUCATION.
BASED ON NATIONAL EDUCATION
STANDARDS FOR IMMUNIZATION
TRAINING FOR THAT. FROM THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION THE MUSICIAN
TRAINING COVERS IMMUNOLOGY
EPIDEMIOLOGY EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE IMPLEMENTATION.
CLINICAL EVALUATION OF PATIENT
HISTORY FOR PATIENT SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION. TECHNIQUES ON
APPROACHING VACCINE HESITANCY
PROPER MANAGEMENT OF ADVERSE
REACTIONS OR EMERGENCIES AND
STRATEGIES ON INCREASING
VACCINATIONRATES. IN ADDITION
TO THE FOUNDATIONAL
IMMUNIZATION TRAINING
PHARMACISTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE ONE HOUR
OF ONGOING CONTINUING PHARMACY
EDUCATION. FOCUSED ON
IMMUNIZATION AND VACCINES
DURING EACH LICENSE RENEWAL
PERIOD TO MAINTAIN THEIR
AUTHORITY TO IMMUNIZE. THIS
TRAINING PROGRAM COMBINED WITH
A DOCTOR OF PHARMACY DEGREE
LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS AND
DEDICATION TO CONTINUING
EDUCATION MAKES PHARMACISTS
HIGHLY QUALIFIED TO ASSESS
PATIENTS FOR INDICATIONS. AND
CONTRA INDICATIONS AND THEN
SAFELY VACCINATE. UNDER CURRENT
LAW THE PHARMACISTS ARE
AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE ALL
VACCINES WHICH IS ON HE
ROUTINE SCHEDULE BY THE CDC
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES A. T. I.
P. AS WELL TO COVER NINETEEN
VACCINE. WHILE THE FDA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVALUATING THE
SAFETY AND EFFICACY OF VACCINES
AND APPROVING THE INDICATIONS
THE EASY PART. THE I. P. MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON A
VARIETY OF FACTORS INCLUDING
POPULATION HEALTH. ACTING
EFFECTIVENESS AND COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THAT ARE DESIGNED TO
BENEFIT THE GENERAL POPULATION.
ON THE H. ONE N. ONE PANDEMIC
TO AS RECENTLY AS COVER
NINETEEN. PHARMACIST PLAYED A
VITAL ROLE IN ENSURING OUR
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE THE VACCINE
IS NECESSARY TO SAVE LIVES.
THERE WAS THE POTENTIAL FOR
DELAYING PATIENT ACCESS TO LIFE
SAVING VACCINES GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THE VACCINES WERE NOT
RECOGNIZED AS THE C. I. P.
ROUTINE. VACCINATIONS BY THE
CDC COMMITTEE. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE ACCESS TO VACCINATIONS
TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS BY
AUTHORIZING PHARMACISTS
ADMINISTER ALL AT THE APPROVED
VACCINATIONS. FOR PATIENTS
THREE YEARS AND OLDER. FINALLY
THIS CHANGES ABOUT INCREASING
ACCESS POINT FOR PATIENTS WHO
CHOOSE TO RECEIVE FDA APPROVED
AND AUTHORISED ACTING. IN THE
RECENT YEARS WHEN THERE HAS
BEEN AN OUTBREAK OF PREVENTABLE
DISEASES PHARMACISTS WERE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO PROVIDE CERTAIN
VACCINES. THIS DID NOT CREATE A
MANDATE THIS IS A CHOICE TO
RECEIVE A VACCINE WILL REMAIN
BETWEEN A PATIENT AND THEIR
CHILDREN HEALTHCARE PROVIDER
INCLUDING PHARMACISTS. WITH
THIS I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND REQUEST AND I VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
YOUR WORK WERE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. LET'S NOW
TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE A. B. ONE ZERO SIX
FOUR. PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF-
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS WHEN
THE GOAL HORN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG
STORES AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A
B. ONE ZERO SIX FOUR. SEEING NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CARE ACT TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF BABY JUST SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH WINE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBER THERE BUT ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IMPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND THE
FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE P. TEN SIXTY FOUR. AND
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME
NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP. YUP
ONE MOMENT JUST AS WE SAID THAT
ONE SECOND PLEASE. THE
OPERATORS GIVING THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER. I HAVE A LITTLE
LINE EIGHTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TEMPLE THERE ON- WITH
THE WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
HEALTH SYSTEM PHARMACISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S NOT-FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE ZERO SIX FOUR SEEING NO
SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT. ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
ZERO SIX FOUR. WE WILL PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO TEN SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND ONE MORE REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND ALL
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS AND
OPINIONS. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND- SUMMER SONG- IT DID. HAVE
SOME A QUESTION ABOUT THE BILL
HAD. PARTIALLY BASED ON THE
PRESENTATION AND SOME OF THE
COMMENTS BY THE SUPPORTERS AND
ANALYSIS THAT- IT AT THE MINUTE
DOES RAISE SOME CONCERN SO I
SAY FUNDAMENTALLY I BELIEVE THE
PURPOSE OF YOUR BILL IS TO
ESSENTIALLY ALLOW PHARMACISTS
TO ALSO ADMINISTER. VACCINES
HAVE BEEN APPROVED THAT ARE NOT
NECESSARY PART OF ROUTINE
SCHEDULE SO I KNOW WHERE THE
VACCINES AS MENTIONED FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE YELLOW FEVER
VACCINE OR OTHER TYPES OF
VACCINES- THAT BEEN APPROVED BY
THE FDA BUT I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT- EACH ONE OF THOSE
VACCINES ACTUALLY HAS- THE ACIP
GIVING RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO
WHO APPROPRIATELY GETS THE
VACCINE AND IN WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES SELL- I GUESS MY
CONCERN IS THAT WHAT I'VE HEARD
IN YOUR PRESENTATION AND EVEN
IN SOME OF THE COMMENTS AND BY
THE SUPPORTERS HERE IN ANALYSIS
IS THAT. THE DESIRE TO GIVE
VACCINES THAT HAVE BEEN FDA
APPROVED BUT THE AC I. T. IS
NOT PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING THEIR- WHO SHOULD GET
THEM AND UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I WOULD MAKE
NOTE OF THAT- EVEN FOR COVET
THE COVETED ACT SCENES THAT-
WE'VE JUST DONE EVEN IN THE
PRESS OF OUR- CURRENT PANDEMIC-
EVEN AFTER FIFTY- EARTH EARLY
USE AUTHORIZATION. THEY WERE
NOT BEGUN TO BE ADMINISTERED
AND TELL THE A. C. I. T. IT'S
DONE ITS REVIEW AS TO WHO
SHOULD GET THE VACCINE UNDER
WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES. AND THAT'S
THE WAY. WE DO THINGS TO BE
SURE THAT THE PRO PEOPLE GET
THE VACCINES. AT THE PROPERTY
AND APPROPRIATE CIRCUMSTANCES
IT SAID IT'S NOT JUST THE FDA
APPROVAL ALONE IT IS THE FDA.
FOLLOWED BY THE A. C. I. T. THE
EVENTS ARE COMEDIANS ASIAN
PRACTICE WHICH PART OF THE CDC.
SO I AM A LITTLE CONCERNED
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEIR
STATEMENTS LIKE- THE FDA. C. I.
T. TAKES TOO LONG SO. THE MEANS
THAT OUR- CAN BE A- OUTSIDE OF
ACTIVE MINISTER VACCINES THEY
HAVEN'T HAD A SAFETY
RECOMMENDATIONS. BECAUSE QUOTE
THEY TAKE TOO LONG EXCEPT- THEN
WHO ARE THEY GIVING THEM TWO
AND UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO I THINK THIS NEEDS
CLARIFICATION- BECAUSE
OTHERWISE I THINK WORK FOR YOU
KNOW AND I GUESS THE THING THAT
SCARES ME IS THAT- THE PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BE ADMINISTERING
THESE VACCINES AND DO NOT SEEM
TO BE VERY AWARE OF THE ROLE
THE A. C. I. T. AND SO THAT
THAT'S- THAT'S- THAT'S A BIT.
THAT CONCERNING AND I WOULD
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT- I KNOW MY
OFFICE IT REACHED OUT TO YOUR
OFFICE AND THEY MADE REFERENCE
TO THE- LEGEND YOU KNOW THE
PASSAGE OF AB SEVENTEEN TEN
LAST SESSION REGARDING KOBE BUT
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT. YOU
KNOW WHEN I WENT BACK AND TOOK
A LOOK AT THE BILL. VERY
CLEARLY SAID THAT EVEN FOR
COVERT VACCINE IT WOULD BE
BASED ON- A C. I. T. THAT WAS
ACTUALLY STATED STRICTLY THAT.
SPECIFICALLY IN THAT PARTICULAR
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED I
WAS PROUD OF THAT FOR THAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION SO. I SO I
THINK I'M FINE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE BUT I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT- THAT THE
STATEMENTS AROUND EIGHT C. I.
P. I KNOW YOU DID SAY IT TOWARD
THE END OF YOUR PRESENTATION.
THAT YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO GET
AROUND A C. I. T. BUT I THINK
IT NEEDS TO BE MUCH MORE
EXPLICITLY STATED BECAUSE- AND
IN THE BILL BECAUSE I BECAUSE
IT SAID I'M I'M HEARING ALSO IN
PRESENT. AND SUPPORT LETTERS
THAT THEY THEY TALK ABOUT.
TRYING TO DO THIS BEFORE THE
ACA P. EVEN GIVES
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THAT TO ME
WOULD BE VERY CONCERNING. SO
PERHAPS- YOU CAN CLARIFY. THAT
THE INTENTS. OF FILE. WHAT DO
YOU WISH TO HAPPEN- WITH WITH
THAT IT. IS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL I MEAN THIS IS THIS ARE WE
GONNA HAVE IS THIS I MEAN. ARE
WE HAVE PHARMACISTS GIVING
VACCINES THAT HAVE JUST
RECEIVED FDA APPROVAL PRIOR TO
A C. I. T. RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO THE- WHO'S APPROPRIATELY. HE
SHOULD PROBABLY GET THE
VACCINES AND WHAT IT'S A-
REMEMBER SO I APPRECIATE THE-
BUT THE QUESTION IS THE CONCERN
AND CERTAINLY- I WILL DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUE- FROM SAN JOSE WHO
AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN TEN WHO'S
HERE WHO CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- ON THIS BILL SAYS
SIMPLY SAYS THAT WE WANT TO
EXPAND- THE RULES COMMITTEE
PHARMACIES ACAP- AS GOOD AS IT
DOES MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
VACCINES AND PHARMACISTS WILL
FOLLOW THE C. I. P.
RECOMMENDATION- IT'S PART OF
THE TRAINING AS MENTIONED BY-
BUT MY WITNESS THAT IS THE BEST
PRACTICE THE PHARMACIST BUT IN
THE CONFUSION THAT EXISTS RIGHT
NOW IS THAT. THERE IS ALSO AN
ACAP ROUTINE LISTED SCHEDULE IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE ACIP
RECOMMENDATION ON BACKS OF
ATTACKS NATIONS THE ROUTINE
SCHEDULE IS WHAT PHARMACISTS
ARE CURRENTLY ONLY ALLOWED TO
MINISTER IN THE ROUTINE
SCHEDULE CERTAIN VACCINES
RECORDED DEFINED AS ROUTINE
HOWEVER OTHERS MAY INTERPRET
THAT NON ROUTINE OVER INTERPRET
THOSE VACCINATIONS THAT ARE
DEEMED NON LATINO DESTRUCTION
UNDER THE STRICTEST
INTERPRETATION PHARMACISTS ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO MINISTER THOSE-
VACCINATIONS SO I THINK THAT
THE LANGUAGE CONFUSION IS THAT
WE FOLLOW THE ACIP
RECOMMENDATION WHAT THIS BILL
IS DOING IS TO ALLOW
PHARMACISTS TO PROVIDE. THOSE
VACCINES THE ON THE ROUTINE
THIS THAT MAY NOT BE DEEMED NON
ROUTINE OKAY SO I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD ASK IS THAT. DO YOU
COMMIT THAT AND TO. OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE RIGHT TO BEFORE THIS BILL
SHOWS UP ON THE- TO CLARIFY
THAT THE PHARMACISTS- IF
THEY'RE GIVING VACCINES. WILL
BE DOING YET- THE A. C. I. T.
RECOMMENDATIONS SO AND THAT AND
NOT JUST BECAUSE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW JUST AS FDA APPROVAL SO
THERE'S A- GAP AND YOU KNOW
THERE COULD BE VERY SHORT AS I
SAID WITH THAT COVETED
LITERALLY WAS IN WITHIN A WEEK
WHERE THE A. C. I. T. DID THE
REVIEW AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT- I'LL TELL
YOU AS A PHYSICIAN I'D DO WE
DON'T GIVE VACCINES UNTIL THE
A. C. I. T. IS SPOKEN TO. WE DO
WE DON'T JUST WAIT FOR THE FDA
AND GIVE ITSELF I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION- AND IN FACT I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE PRIOR
LEGISLATION YEAH THAT WAS FOR
TWO ALSO HAD THAT KIND OF
LANGUAGE IN THERE. SO I THINK
SO IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
GET LIKE A YELLOW FEVER VACCINE
FINE WITH THAT BUT THERE'S
ACTUALLY A C. I. T.
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WHO SHOULD
GET IT AND SO FORTH SO. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE BILL
HAS THAT CLAIFICATION IN THERE
BECAUSE- I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
TO TRAVEL I THINK JEMELE
PHARMACISTS WILL DO THAT. I
THINK THERE'S SOME CONFUSION
ESPECIALLY GIVEN SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS BEING MADE ABOUT THE
BILL- THAT I SAW ON THE
ANALYSIS AND FRANKLY EVEN YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU START OFF BY
MAKING A COMMENT ABOUT THE C.
I. T. THAT WAS THAT SOMETIMES
THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO WAIT
AND- THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE
VERY CONCERNING NO I WENT AND
CERTAINLY WOULD WOULD WOULD
PLEDGE AND WORK WITH YOU AND TO
SWITCH THOSE CONCERNS- THE-
WE'VE LEARNED. EARLY THAT
THROUGH THE SPEND AND MAKE THAT
THE ROLE OF PHARMACISTS IS
CRITICAL BOARD TO RELIEVE THE
STRESS ON ON ON THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM SO THE GOAL OF THIS IS
SIMPLY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
COMMUNITY PHARMACIES ALLOW
THOSE BUT THOSE VACCINATION
SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY THEM.
BUT THERE IS NO DESIRE FOR IT
EVER TO BYPASS THEY SAID P.
RECOMMENDATION PROCESS IT IS
SOON TO BE A MINISTER'S
VACCINES THAT ARE DEEMED NOT
ROUTINE SO HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU OKAY ALL RIGHT I APPRECIATE
THAT- I HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET IT
WITH THAT CLARIFICATION THEN-
THAT I THINK THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL I'M I'M. GOING TO STAY
OFF THE BILL THE COMMITTEE FOR
AT I APPRECIATE PLEDGE A LOOK
THE WORKING WITH YOU. AND
HOPEFULLY WE GET THIS- BEFORE
THE BILL SHOWS A ON THE FLOOR
YOU. I THANK THE GENTLEMAN
COLLEAGUES ANY FURTHER.
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SEEING
NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FARM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST
RESPECT ME AS RIVAL THANK YOU
SIR DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO SIX FOUR.
SENATOR TYLER WAS MOVED THE
BILL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM THREE AB TEN
SIXTY FOUR D. PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH HI RALPH
HI MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. OR
CHILL OUT I BEAT. BACKER ALL
RIGHT BACKER HI DONNA HI DONNA
HI A MAN. EIGHT MEN I HER TADO
I TAUGHT I Y. JONES JONES I
LEAVE A MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN. AT
SHOW ABODE HI A TERRIBLE JOKE
IPN. BILL HAS NINE VOTES HOLD
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT LET'S MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR WHEN SIMPLY BILL. ONE
THREE TWO EIGHT. REMEMBER WHEN
YOU HAVE ONE BUILT A PRESENT
TODAY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THREE
TWO EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WILL AUTHORIZE
PHARMACISTS MORE FULLY ENGAGE
AND PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIVITIES
AND ALLOW THEM TO ADMINISTER
MANY CLIA WAIVED TESTS. I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING TO
REFINE THE LANGUAGE IN THIS
BILL AND I'M ALSO ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
PHARMACISTS PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM BY UTILIZING
THEIR EXPERTISE AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY PATIENT CARE.
CALIFORNIA HAS A HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN OVER TAXED
BY THE PANDEMIC A RAPIDLY AGING
POPULATIONS AND COMMUNITIES
WITH POOR ACCESS TO PHYSICIANS
AND OTHER PRACTITIONERS
PRACTITIONERS. PHARMACISTS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT PERMITTED TO
PROVIDE MORE THAN A FEW OF THE
CLIA WAIVED TESTS THOUGH THESE
TESTS ARE DEFINED BY THE FDA IS
SIMPLE TESTS WITH THE LOW RISK
FOR AN INCORRECT RESULTS. IT
DEFINITELY PHARMACISTS ARE
CURRENTLY ONLY ALLOWED TO
PROVIDE HEALTH SCREENINGS FOR
CONDITIONS THAT ARE DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE MEDICATION
REGIMENS. THIS FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE THE KEY ROLE THAT
PHARMACISTS ARE. CONSERVATIVE
PREVENTS TO REDUCE OR MITIGATE
PROGRESSION OF DISEASE BY
CONDUCTING SCREENINGS AND
REFERRING PATIENTS TO A
POSITION AT THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT MINIMIZES BARRIERS IN
CURRENT LAW BY PERMITTING
PHARMACISTS TO ADMINISTER CLIA
WAIVED TESTS. WITH AND WITH
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS OF WITH
CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS AND WITH THE
PATIENT'S APPROVAL NOTIFYING
THE PATIENT'S PHYSICIAN OF THE
RESULTS IF THE PATIENT DOESN'T
HAVE A PHYSICIAN THE PHARMACIST
WILL PROVIDE THE PATIENT A LIST
OF PHYSICIANS CLINICS OR OTHER.
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO CONTACT REGARDING CARE FOR A
NORMAL RESULTS THIS PANDEMIC
HAS MADE US ACUTELY AWARE OF
THE SHORTCOMINGS AND BARRIERS
IN OUR HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. PARTICULARLY FOR
UNDERSERVED. POPULATIONS AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT EXPAND
ACCESS CARE. AND EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF ACUTE AND
CHRONIC DISEASES. AND THIS
IMPROVES THE QUALITY AND CARE
AND LENGTH OF LIFE WHILE
REDUCING ECONOMIC BURDEN. I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON THIS
IMPORTANT. HEALTH CARE MEASURES
AND I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
KEVIN GROCERY YOSHI'S DUCA
BECAUSE THE IS A TEAM. HAS TORO
AND ERIC HE- THANK YOU
WITNESSES PLEASE PROCEED. DR
GTO JUGA PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS AND
ASSISTANT DEAN FOR
ADMINISTRATION AT TORY
UNIVERSITY CLLEGE OF PHARMACY
AND LICENSES THE PHARMACISTS
AND AN ATTORNEY IN CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS HAVE A LONG HISTORY
OF ORDERING AND INTERPRETING
LAPTOPS AND CALIFORNIA GOING
BACK FIFTY YEARS WORKING AS
PART OF A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
HEALTHCARE TEAM. TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE GRANTED EVERY
PHARMACIST IN THE STATE IF THE
READY TO ORDER INTERPRET LAB
TESTS TO MONITOR THE EFFICACY
AND TOXICITY OF DRUG THERAPY.
AT THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
PREVENT PHARMACISTS TO PERFORM
SOME OF THE SAME TEST THAT ARE
CLIA WAIVED TO PROVIDE PATIENTS
WITH RESULTS. IN MINUTES
INSTEAD OF DAYS. HI A TEST OF
BE FRIDAY TO SIMPLE.
EXAMINATION AND PROCEDURES THAT
IN INSIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF RISK
OF EVERYONE IS RESULT. EIGHTY
THIRTY TWENTY EIGHT WOULD ALSO
REMOVE THE CURRENT RESTRICTIONS
THE TEST. THE ONLY USE THE
MONITOR FOR EFFICACY AND
TOXICITY OF DRUG THERAPY THE
PHARMACIST CAN ENGAGE IN PUBLIC
HEALTH SCREENINGS TO THAT
IDENTIFY. POTENTIAL PUBLIC
HEALTH HAZARDS AS AN EARLY
ENTRY POINT. TO THE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT CAN PULL.
A GENOCIDAL CHRONIC INFECTIOUS
DISEASE EARLY TO CONNECT
PATIENTS WITH PHYSICIANS FOR
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON THIS BILL WILL NOT TURN IT
OVER TO DR ERIC IT WILL
DESCRIBE. AS LITTLE PRACTICE
AND TRAINING THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING NAME IS DR ERIC GET
CHAIR AND PROFESSOR OF CLINICAL
FINDING THAT TORE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF PHARMACY.
AND THE CLINICAL PHARMACIST AT
KAISER PERMANENTE A MOUNTAIN
VIEW PRIMARY CARE DEPARTMENT OF
A PANEL OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PATIENTS WITH DIABETES OR
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE. RIGHT
FOR SCRIBING TO JUST MEDICATION
AS WELL AS ME KEENLY ORDER
INTERPRET AND MONITOR THE LAB
WORK IMMERSED HEINZ EACH DAY TO
DETERMINE HOW WELL CONTROL MY
PATIENTS ARE WITH THEIR
CONDITION. AS WELL AS THE
TURNING THE SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
MEDICATION. REGARDING FORMER
EDUCATION IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT DOCTOR OF
PHARMACY PROGRAM THE TYPICALLY
FOR YEARS AND MANY. SIMILAR TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL. THE MOST COMMON
CURRICULUM CONSISTS OF THREE
YEARS OF CLASSROOM TRAINING.
AND ONE YEAR CLERKSHIP IN
VARIOUS SETTINGS FOR EXAMPLE
CLINICS. HOSPITALS OR COMMUNITY
PHARMACIES. THE PHARMACY AND
YOU OCCUR BY WORK THE CREW. THE
CALL LAB DATA APPLICATION FOR
DISEASE STATE MANAGEMENT WHICH
INCLUDES SCREENING. DIAGNOSIS
PROGRESSION AND TREATMENT
EVALUATION. IN THE CLASSROOM
STUDENTS LEARN THE FOUNDATIONS
ON HOW TO ORDER INTERPRET AND
MONITOR LEVEL. WHEN THEY GO OUT
ON THE FRONT PORCH IF YOU
DIDN'T GAIN HANDS ON EXPERIENCE
IN THE CLINICAL SETTING. PEOPLE
ARE BEING A LICENSED PHARMACIST
IN CALIFORNIA THE GRADUATE MUST
HAVE BOTH THE CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONAL LICENSING EXAMINATIONS
WHICH REQUIRE ENTRY LEVEL
DEPARTMENT THAT. SHOULD BE ABLE
TO PROPERLY AKANE INTERPRET
THAT IN THE VALUATION
LABORATORY AND DIAGNOSTIC
FINDINGS. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SIMPLY
ADD. TO THE LIST OF OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
ABLE TO PERFORM PRE AWAY
PERHAPS. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
I VOTE ON A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU PLEASE. THAT
MUST CONCLUDE YOUR WITNESSES
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SO LET'S TURN
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THREE TWO EIGHT. THANK YOU HIDE
IN ONE SINGLE HORN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG
STORES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
LET'S TURN TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE THREE TWO EIGHT. SEEING
NONE LET'S TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THREE TWO EIGHT WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU WOULD YOU
CARE TO IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT
FOR A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT. I'M ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP. FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
BUT YET ONE ZERO TO PUT
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE. AT OUR
FIRST PARTICIPANT WILL BE LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- AND DR JOHN PAUL P.
DIRECTOR OF PHARMACY AT
PIONEERS MORAL HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT. IN BRAWLEY CALIFORNIA
AN OWNER THE PHARMACIST IN
CHARGE AT THAT PHARMACY AN
INDEPENDENT RETAIL PHARMACY
LOCATED. IN EL CENTRO
CALIFORNIA. FREEWAY TESTING IS
NOT ONLY RELEVANT TO THE FACT
THAT THE PHARMACY IS THE
PHARMACISTS ARE ALSO TRAINED IN
PERFORMING THESE TESTS I MEAN
HEALTHCARE SETTING. THE WAY
pINDIGENT COMMUNITY I SIR. MANY
MANY HARD TO REACH TEENS
PHARMACIES ARE READILY
ACCESSIBLE AND IT'S WELL KNOWN
THAT MANY INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES ARE LOCATED WITHIN
WALKING DISTANCE TO. MOST OF
THE POPULATION RESIDES AND
PROVIDING MORE READY ACCESS TO
CLEAR IT TESTING WHAT WE LACK
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE. HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND URGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR
OF- DISASSEMBLED BILL THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
ANNEX GO TO LINE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR OPEN. GET YOUR NUMBERS
MICHAEL HAWKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE U. B. K. BECAUSE FROM
SUPPORT OF PASSAGE BILL TODAY
AND INCLUSION I GO BY THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS
LET'S NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. I
BELIEVE- EMILY HUGHES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
INTO MADDEN REPRESENTING
VARIOUS. PHYSICIAN GROUPS ARE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PROCEED.
YES GOOD MORNING SHERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EMILY HUGHES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT I
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR BEING
UNABLE TO SPEAK TO EACH OF THE
AMENDMENTS AS DESPITE OUR
EFFORTS TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE
SPONSORS WE WERE NOT MADE AWARE
OF THEM UNTIL LATE LAST NIGHT.
OUR GENERAL CONCERNS AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IS THAT
IS A BROAD OVERREACH IN THE
SCOPE EXPANSION OF PHARMACISTS
POTENTIALLY ENCROACHING ON
PRIMARY CARE AND ONCOLOGY.
ALLOWING PHARMACISTS TO ORDER
ADMINISTER AND INTERPRET CLIA
WAIVED TESTS WITHIN NARROW
EXCLUSION SEAMY TAKES ISSUE
WITH THE APPROPRIATENESS OF THE
SETTING IN PROTECTION WHEN IT
COMES TO CERTAIN SAMPLES. WE
FEEL AS THOUGH THE PHARMACY IS
NOT INAPPROPRIATE PLEASE BE
COLLECTING AND TESTING VAGINAL
SWABS SIEMENS VESTMENTS FOR
PERFORMING VENIPUNCTURE. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AS
AMENDED READS SPECIMEN
COLLECTION MAY BE DONE ONSITE
ASSESSMENT COLLECTION IS DONE
ON SITE IT MAY IT BE PERFORMED
BY THE PATIENT. AND GIVEN A
DEDICATED SPACE THAT PROVIDES
FOR PRIVACY DURING SPECIMEN
COLLECTION. MAY ALLOW IS THAT A
PHARMACIST MAY BE COLLECTING
THE SPECIMENS. WERE FAMOUSLY
OPPOSED TO VAGINAL SWABS OF
SEMEN SPECIMENS BEING COLLECTED
BY PHARMACISTS AND OR IN
PHARMACIES. FURTHERMORE WE TAKE
GREAT ACTION ISSUE BUT THE
MATTER OF INTERPRETATION.
DESPITE HIS HAS BEEN CLASSIFIED
AS SIMPLE TO ADMINISTER IT IS
OUR POSITION THAT WHEN ANY
HEALTHCARE IN ANY HEALTHCARE
SETTING WITH A HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL. PATIENTS HAVE A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF A
GREATER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DISEASE OR CONDITION BEING
TESTED THAN THEY WOULD IN THEIR
OWN HOME. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
PHARMACISTS HAVE SUFFICIENT
EDUCATION TRAINING AND THE
DISEASES AND CONDITIONS THAT
THE FOURTEEN HUNDRED CLIA
WAIVED TESTS ADDRESS WHICH
PRECLUDES THEM FROM PROVIDING
ACCURATE INFORMATION ON RESULTS
AND ENSURING. PROPER REFERRAL
AND FOLLOW UP CARE. LASTLY BEEN
LISTING TO BE ALLOWS FOR
EXPANSION OF THE PATIENT
ASSESSMENT PHARMACISTS WOULD BE
A LOT PERFORM. EXAMPLES GIVEN
BY SPONSOR OF THESE ASSESSMENTS
INCLUDE BONE DENSITY AND
DEPRESSION AMONG OTHERS. C.
MADE FRIENDS AT WILDLY.
INAPPROPRIATE FOR PHARMACISTS
TO BE PERFORMING SUCH COMPLEX
TESTS AND THOSE WITH WIDE
RANGING MENTAL HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS OF ASSESSING THESE
THINGS SHOULD BE LEFT TO
PHYSICIANS TRAINED IN THESE
CONDITIONS IN THESE CONDITIONS.
FORTUNATELY AS BEFORE NINE
SPONSORED BY THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY IS CURRENTLY IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND HAS RECEIVED SIGN
OFF FROM SEVERAL THE OPPONENTS
OF THIS BILL. AS IT PRUDENTLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUES THIS
LEGISLATION PRESENTS ITSELF.
FOR THESE REASONS AS WE OPPOSE
THE OVER REACHING EIGHTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BEFORE US
TODAY WE ASKED TO CONSIDER
ASKING FOR A NINE. AS A SAFER
ALTERNATIVE ROUTE WHEN IT
RETURNS THIS HOUSE. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE MISTRETTA. THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS DEMAND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY PLASTIC
SURGEONS IN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY WE ARE OPPOSED AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
SPECIFICALLY TO THE LANGUAGE
MOST EXPANSIVE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR PHARMACISTS TO
PERFORM PATIENT ASSESSMENT
PROCEDURES AND HEALTH
SCREENINGS WE RECOGNIZE THESE
ACTIVITIES WOULD ONLY BE
ALLOWED FOR PHARMACISTS IN
CERTAIN SETTINGS WITHOUT ANY
DEFINITION OF WHAT WOULD BE
INCLUDED IN PATIENT ASSESSMENT
PROCEDURES AND HEALTH
SCREENINGS WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED. THIS WILL RESULT IN
A PHARMACIST PERFORMING
PROCEDURES BEYOND THEIR
TRAINING AND EDUCATION I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS- SCOPE IS SO
DEFINED TO ALLOW THEM TO
PERFORM ANY PATIENT ASSESSMENT
PROCEDURE OR HEALTH SCREENINGS
WITHOUT ANY DEFINITION OF WHAT
THAT OF WHAT THIS INCLUDES OR
WHAT TRAINING EDUCATION IS
NEEDED TO. PROVIDE THERE'S BEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR EVALUATION ON
WHETHER PHARMACIST RECEIVES
ADEQUATE EDUCATION AND TRAINING
TO PERFORM THESE PROCEDURES.
THERE'S BEEN NO DISCUSSION OF
THE TRAINING IS CONSISTENT FROM
ONE PHARMACY SCHOOL TO THE
NEXT. THE ONLY REQUIREMENTS FOR
FIRMS TO PERFORM THESE
PROCEDURES IS A COMPLETE A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM OR- THEY HAVE
DEMONSTRATED EXPERIENCE IN
PATIENTS. AND DIRECT PATIENT
CARE. THESE REQUIREMENTS AND NO
WAY INSURE THE PHARMACIST IS
QUALIFIED TO BE DOING THESE
PROCEDURES EVEN IF THEY ARE IN
A SETTING WITH OTHER HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR NOTE OF. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. SIR
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF BRENT
SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE WE'RE NOT POSITION
FOR ALL THE REASONS STATED BY
MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THREE TWO
EIGHT. I SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE THREE TWO EIGHT. WE'LL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR CHAIR- TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
LIKE NINETY TWO. VISITOR
NUMBERS PRODUCT NUMBER AVE THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGIST IN
OPPOSITION TO EITHER P. TWENTY.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. AND MISTER KERR NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
COLLINGS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS REGARDING THIS
MEASURE- CENTER LABEL FOLLOWED
BY SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I JUST- I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE OTHERS
TRYING TO DO BUT AS SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTED PHARMACISTS FOR
MANY YEARS THEY ARE
UNDERSTAFFED AND OVERWORKED AND
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW THEY WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE THE THEY'RE SMART
ENOUGH FOR SURE. BUT I JUST
DON'T SEE HOW THEY WILL HAVE
THE CAPABILITY OR THE CAPACITY
TO ACTUALLY DO ALL OF THESE
ADDITIONAL TESTS SO I LOVE MY
PHARMACIST I THINK THAT SHE IS
AMAZING AND KNOWS SO MUCH. BUT
HAVING THEM DO THESE ADDITIONAL
TESTS AND WE KNOW THAT MANY
COMPANIES WILL NOT PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL HOURS FOR THEM THEY
WON'T PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
PHARMACISTS I'M JUST CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO STRETCH A
STRETCH THESE FOLKS WHO ALREADY
DOING. A YEOMAN'S JOB-
RESTRICTION ME THE THINNER SO
I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY AND
HOPE THAT WE GET TO A POINT
WHERE WE KNOW THAT THESE
PHARMACISTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
THE HELP THEY NEED TO DO THIS.
AND I DO HAVE SOME MILDER
CONCERNS ABOUT THE VAGINAL
SWABBING AND THE- THE SEMEN
TESTS BUT MOSTLY I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THE PHARMACIST. THANK YOU
SIR LOUIS SENTIMENT. I HAD A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR- SO WE
PASSED SB FOUR OH NINE BY
SENATOR CAFIERO EARLIER THIS
YEAR. IN THAT HAD A MORE
LIMITED EXPANSION OF TESTING.
AND I GUESS I WAS JUST CURIOUS-
YOU KNOW I CAN SEE THE VALUE OF
HAVING IN YOUR PHARMACY BEING
ABLE TO GETALL THESE SORTS OF
TESTS- I COULD ALSO SEE
CONCERNS AROUND LIABILITY IN
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY.
SOME OF THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- INSIDE I GUESS YOU
KNOW THE ARGUMENT THAT'S IN MY
HEAD IS THAT. THE BEST BEFORE-
NINE TAKES A MORE MEASURED
APPROACH AND I GUESS I WANTED
TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY-
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR ARGUMENT FOR
WHY WE SHOULD GO WHOLE HOG HERE
IN AN OPEN UP- HUNDREDS OR
THOUSANDS I THINK OF MORE
TESTS. ARE THEY CAN BE FOR
PERFORM THE PHARMACIES THANK
YOU- THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SP FOUR OH NINE ACTUALLY WHEN
YOU VOTED ON IT DID NOT HAVE-
THE- THE SAME BILL ENACTED THAT
BILL WAS CHANGE ONCE IT MOVED
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY AND I
THINK- THE REAL BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN. SP FOUR OH NINE AND MY
BILL IS THAT- WE SHOULD SHE
BASICALLY HAS AN OFTEN AND THIS
IS AN AN OPT OUT. BUT THE IDEA
IN BOTH OF THE BILLS IS
ACTUALLY TO EXPAND ESPECIALLY
INTO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THESE CLEAR WAYS WE HAVE WAIVED
TESTS THESE ARE TESTS THAT.
AGAIN ARE- DEFINED BY THE FDA
IS SIMPLE TASKS WITH. VERY LOW
RISK FOR AN INCORRECT RESULT.
AND I'M JUST TO ANSWER THE
CONCERN FROM SENATOR LEYVA-
THE- PHARMACISTS ALL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK TO ACTUALLY
OFTEN TO- TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
TESTING SO REAL WE REALLY WOULD
SEE THAT THIS IS MORE.
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE DOING THIS THAT ARE
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
AND AS- EASIER CONNECTION TO A
PHYSICIAN. SO WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE PHARMACISTS HAVE
BEEN FIT WORKING VERY HARD
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND WE
CERTAINLY WOULDN'T EXPECT THEM
TO TAKE THIS ON UNLESS THEY
THINK THAT THEY HAVE- THE
CAPACITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES IN THE FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'D
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IPHONE. OKAY DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THREE TWO EIGHT. CENTER
ARCHULETA HAS MOVED THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RIVER
FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT G.
PASSES AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROTH. ROTH I'M MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA BURCHILL OUT IBEATS
BACKER BY BECKER I DON HI DON I
EGGMAN EGGMAN I. HER TADO I.
FURTADO I JONES LLEVA. MAN
NEWMAN NEWMAN I TO ABODE I'M
THAT SHOW A BUG EYED PEON. BILL
HAS EIGHT VOTES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU. SEVEN MEMBER LOCAL
MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE SEVERAL
MEASURES STARTING WITH THE
NUMBERS ITEM NUMBER SIX SIMPLY
BILL- LEVIN. NINETY FOUR.
RECEIVE ONE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AS THIS IS A SERIES THIS WILL
BE A SERIES OF BILLS WITH
RESPECT TO SUNSETS AND-
BUSINESS BEFORE THE VISIT OF
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. THIS IS
A SYMBOL OF A NINETY FOUR TO
HELP. ENSURE THAT WE REFORM OUR
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. MY NOTES- REFLECT-
RICK BLACK IS ON THE LINE MR
LOWE IS THAT CORRECT OKAY.
PLEASE PROCEED- MISTER BLACK.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
YOUR STAFF WAS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A GREAT DEAL OF THE NINETY
FOUR. MY NAME'S WORK BLACK
DIRECTORS. THE CENTER FOR THE
STATE ADMINISTRATION REFORM.
WE'RE A FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE
AN ADVOCATE FOR SINGERS AND
INTELLECTUALLY IMPAIRED ADULTS
TARGETED BY THE PREDATORY LEGAL
COMMUNITY IN POWER OF ATTORNEY
TRIES IN ADULT THIRTY
CONSERVATORSHIP FRAUDS. WE'VE
COUNSELED OUR RESEARCH NEARLY
FOUR THOUSAND CONSERVATORSHIP
CASES NATIONWIDE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. THE
CONSERVATIVES SYSTEM IS BROKEN
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION WHY
RECOGNIZE STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
ARE TOO OFTEN IGNORED BY COURTS
IN THEIR HASTE TO SATISFY
FELLOW RETURNING. THE JUDICIARY
HAS DEMONSTRATED LITTLE
INTEREST IN INCORPORATING BEST
PRACTICES FOR STOPPING KNOWN
ABUSES THIS BILL AND SENATOR
BEN ALLEN'S AS BEING SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR INCREASES
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THE RIGHT TO INDEPENDENCE
IN YELLOWSTONE SOLD FOR ALLEGED
INCAPACITATED PERSONS. IN THE
ADULT CONSERVATORSHIP EDUCATION
PROCESS. CHABLIS CURRENT
CALIFORNIA STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS DO AS WELL. THE
JUDGES TOO OFTEN IGNORE THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND ENSURE STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS. WE THANK THE THREE
BRITNEY MOVEMENT AND ITS
LEADERS ASSOCIATION MEDIA
SKILLS AND COMMON SENSE THAT
BEAUTIFULLY CAPTURED
LEADERSHIP'S ATTENTION WHERE
MANY PREVIOUSLY JAILED. MUCH
HAS BEEN EXPOSED SINCE MISS
FIGURES SHOCKING TESTIMONY
DURING HER CONSERVATORSHIP
HEARING IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ON JUNE TWENTY THIRD. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE- TESTIMONY
CONTRADICTED THE LONGSTANDING
CLAIMS ON THE MANY ATTORNEYS
WHO BENEFITED FINANCIALLY FROM
HER ISOLATION AND EXPLOITATION.
ASHTEAD GROUP BRITNEY SAMPLE
FIRE CONTINUES TO CRY OUT. HOW
CAN A LOOSE SUCCESSFUL AND
DEVOTED MOTHER BE CONSCRIPTED
INTO A THIRTEEN YEAR
UNNECESSARY AND EXPENSIVE
CONSERVATORSHIP. TO MANY JUDGES
CHOOSE TO ENTERTAIN FELLOW
MEMBERS OF THE BAR INSTEAD OF
PROTECTING THE VULNERABLE THE
LOVED ONES THAT ARE STATE
DOCUMENTS THERE ARE STATE. AND
THE STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS THAT
PROTECT VULNERABLE ADULTS
WHETHER A VIBRANT CELEBRITY BUT
DEMENTIA IMPAIRED OCTOGENARIAN
FR THE EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
CEREBRAL PALSY VICTIM WHO
LOVINGLY CARED FOR BY A PARENT
THIS SYSTEM MUST ENSURE THEIR
PROTECTION. AND THE RIGHT.
SILENCE DICK. AND WORLD WAR
CREDIT TO ATTORNEY. SHOULD
NEVER BE TOLERATED IN THIS
PROCESS. MUCH LESS REWARDED
ASSEMBLYMAN LOADS COMMITMENT TO
A MULTI GENERATIONAL PLAN GIVES
US HOPE THAT THE IMPROVEMENTS
THIS BILL HIGHLIGHTS ALONG WITH
FUTURE MANDATES WILL REDUCE
VICTIMIZATION IN CALIFORNIA.
HERE DOURSON'S EIGHTY ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR AND REQUEST THIS
COMMITTEE'S ENDORSEMENT AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S NOT
HEAR FROM ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY. SAYING NO SUCH
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
SUPPORT OF A SYMBOL OF A NINETY
FOUR. THING NO WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR- AT ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO. AND ONE MORE REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOT
GETTING NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES BEGINNING
WITH WITNESSES. IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND THEN IF I
YOURSELF AFFILIATION AND
POSITION PLEASE HELLO TO
REMEMBERS JEFFREY DOES MEN WITH
THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
NOT IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AT THIS POINT WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE AUTHOR AND
ALL STAKEHOLDERS THE
PROFESSIONAL PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE GOAL
OF THIS MEASURE. WE SHARE THE
INTEREST IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR CONSERVATIVES IN THE
WORDS THAT WE SERVE TO PROTECT.
THE PROVISIONS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON. ARE THOSE THAT ADDRESS
DUE PROCESS FOR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION ABOUT THE FIDUCIARY WHEN
THERE'S BEEN ABUSE. THE GOAL OF
TRANSPARENCY SO THAT THE FEES
OF THE COURT DECIDES. IN THESE
CASES IS KNOWN IN ADVANCE AND
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT THE PROPER
ROLE OF THE COURTS IS WRITTEN
INTO THE MEASURE SO THAT THEY
HAVE THE ROLE TO MAKE THE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS IN THESE
SITUATIONS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. YES SIR MY
NAME IS ROSS MARSHALL AND THEN
THAT- ON THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY SO SHE SHE'LL
CALIFORNIA. WHAT EXPRESS OUR
THANKS TO MISTER LOWE WOULD
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HIM ON.
SOME ISSUES WE HAVE WITH THE
BILL AND I AND OUR COMMITTEE
AND WE THE BIG GAP IS GETTING
SMALLER THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SAYING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR SAYING NO SUCH WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL. ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR WILL PROCEED. PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TWO-
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MR SURE NOBODY IS GIVING
UP. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE SO REMEMBER LOCUST
SURE WOULD YOU LIKE TO COOK I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
TO THINK HE'S ME MR MARSHALL
AND OTHERS TO HELP ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE THAT TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU SIR DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ASSEMBLY BILL
OF NINETY FOUR. MOVED BY
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I LIKE HIM SIX EIGHTY
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR DO YOU PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROTH
IRA MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. TO LET
I BEAT HI BEATS I BACKER.
BACKER I. DODD HI DON I EXAMINE.
FURTADO I'M FURTADO I'D JONES
LEVI HI LEVI MIN. MAIN HI
NEWMAN I KNEW MAN I A SHOW
ABOUT OKAY HI BUT SHOW BOTH I'D
PAN HI HE AND I. LIVE IN VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS SIR. NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FIVE THREE SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS THE CENTER
BILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL WHICH WOULD
EXTEND THE COUNCIL SUNSET DATE
BY ONE YEAR THE BILL ALSO
STATES THAT IF THE LEGISLATORS
INTEND TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
AROUND ISSUES RAISED DURING THE
COUNCIL'S SUNSET HEARING. OVER
THE NEXT YEAR WHILE OUR INTENT
IS TO ALLOW FOR SERIOUS
DISCUSSION OF TRANSITIONING TO
POTENTIAL LICENSURE OF MASSAGED
BY ABOARD ONE ALSO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WE DO NOT PRESUME
WHETHER THAT COURSE OF ACTION
IS APPROPRIATE. THE GOAL IS TO
CONTINUE THE CONERSATION TO
THE SUNRISE PROCESS WHICH WE
ALL KNOW IT'S A TOUGH AND
THOROUGH LOOK AT BOTH THE PROS
LICENSURE WOULD LOOK LIKE IN
THE MEANTIME THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND THE CURRENT OPERATIONS
OF THE COUNCIL AND ITS
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
PRESERVING THE STATUS QUO AS WE
ALLOW FOR MORE TIME AND
DISCUSSION FOR ANALYSIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
A MIS EMBLETON AND MS HOOVER
CHRISTINE WHO WERE ON THE LINE
IF SO PLEASE PROCEED. THIS IS
CHRISTINE HOW ARE THE AMERICAN
MASSAGE THERAPY ASSOCIATION-
THE NPA IS THE LARGEST
NONPROFIT PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION SERVING THE FIVE
THERAPISTS FIVE STUDENTS IN THE
CLASS SCHOOL. STATUS IN
NINETEEN FORTY THREE IN NUMBER
IN FROM NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND HE WORKED AT. THE
AT THE PROFESSION THROUGH
AFRICAN CENTERED. THE NATIONAL.
THE LIKELY THING OF WATCH THEIR
AND ALL DATE. AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION ON THE FACT THAT THE
HEALTH BENEFITS. AN ESTIMATED
SIXTY THOUSAND ACROSS THEIR
FIRST PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER THE FULL EXTENT REMAINS
ON THEM. ABSENT A CLEAR
ACCOUNTING OF THE NUMBER OF
PRACTICAL KNOWLEDGE WITHIN THE
STATE CONSUMERS YOUR
INFORMATION AT RISK AND
SIGNIFICANT POPULATIONS THERE
OTHERS REMAIN FREE TO DO AS
THEY. PLEASE WITHOUT ANY ONE OF
OUR SITE. THE TO INCREASE THE
OP. TO ADD FOR THE WIDE RIGHT.
WATCH THEIR HELLO. THE APPROVED
AMENDMENT THE ABC THIRTY SEVEN
WELL YOU CONFIRM COURT FACTOR
UNTIL TWENTY TWO THREE I AGREE
WITH PENALTY TRANSFER TO A MORE
MY ON. STATE LICENSURE IN
CRUCIAL IN SETTING FINAL LEVEL
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHING A
BOTCHED PRACTICE ATTACKING. AND
WALTER ACCOUNT RATHER. HE'S NOT
HERE HE ADDED PRICE IN THE- AND
SMALL ASHEN HEALTHCARE AS
AFFECTED NON. TREATMENT FOR
CHRONIC PAIN. I'M GONNA GET
THAT WHOLE DEPARTMENT VETERANS.
THE COULDN'T WATCH THEIR- IN A
PAIN MANAGEMENT END OF THE CALL
SERVICE UNDER THE AND VA
CONFORMITY- THE DA AT THE TOP
YET THE GS NINE POSITIONS WERE
LIKELY NEEDS OUR SERVICE BEING
OUT OF IN COURT DATE MY CONCERN.
WHAT. WHAT ALLOW CALIFORNIA
BETTER COULD TAKEN OF THE-
ADDITIONALLY THE FROM AND
SERVICES HAVE TO RECKON AND I A
I'M. AT THE BOTTOM SIDE OF MY
FACE LIKE A BASHED BUT TO BE A
SUPPLEMENTAL PLAN WITHIN
MEDICARE AND PLAN. SIMILAR
MASSAGE THERAPY HADN'T BEEN OUT
THE FACT NON FROM. APPROACHES
PAIN MANAGEMENT SUPPORTED BY
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH. GERMAN HELP AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND HALF FORCED. THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF PHYSICIANS.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND THE JOINT
COMMISSION. AND K. STRONG
SUPPORT AT. FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THAT. THANK YOU MA'AM
A FLORAL EMBLETON IS ON THE
LINE PLEASE PROCEED. LET'S MOVE
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY THIRD SUPPORT
WITNESSES PLEASE PROCEED.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF STATE
YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE. MY
NAME IS LAUREN MCLAUGHLIN I'M A
CALIFORNIA MASSAGE THERAPY
COUNCIL CERTIFIED MASSAGE
THERAPIST IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA. I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN CM TWO
C. HASHAD TWELVE YEARS FOR
THIS EXPERIMENT I DON'T FEEL
THE NEED FOR AN EXTENSION
BEYOND A YEAR NOR FEASIBILITY
STUDY. WOMEN'S HARSH THERAPISTS
ARE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS FOR
THE MOST PART AND WE NEED TO BE
RECOGNIZED AS SUCH PLEASE
LISTEN TO THE INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS PROFESSION RATHER THAN
EMPLOYERS WHO MOSTLY ARE NOT
MASSAGE THERAPIST. I ALSO
SUPPORT AN EXTENSION OF NOT
HOLDING THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
EMFLUX TEST. FOR THIS
ADDITIONAL TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU ALLOCATED ADDITIONAL TIME
TO BECAUSE MS HAMILTON WAS NOT
ON THE LINE SO AS TO THE NEXT
BEAKER NAME AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION ONLY PLEASE. CANADIAN
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY. CONNIE CHAN INDEPENDENT
CMT. ORDERED A B. FIFTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN IT IS TIME TO
ELEVATE OUR PROFESSION WITH THE
STATE LICENSE MY PRACTICE IS A
MEDICAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS
FOCUSED HOWEVER THE COUNTY
EINEN CLASSIFIES ME AS ADULT
ENTERTAINMENT THIS TIME WE WERE
INCLUDED AS MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. THANK YOU I'M A
VERY PATIENT PERSON SO TO THOSE
ON THE LINE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION I MUST
INSIST NAME. AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY LET'S NOW MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE THOSE. SO
PLEASE PROCEED SIR THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRIS KAHN
REPRESENTING MASSAGE ENVY
CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE SUPPORT
OF AMANDA POSITION AND THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU. PERFECT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE GALLERY. LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE FIVE THREE
SEVEN SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
SEVEN. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. SEVEN NUMBER QUEUED UP
AND WE WILL START WITH ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M MYRON WALKER CEO OF
HOLLYWOOD CAREER COLLEGE WE
UPHOLD UNLIMITED ADVANTAGE TO
READ OUR PRIVACY AND HIS PEOPLE
FOR YEARS. THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'RE IN SUPPORT NOW. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT FOR A. B. FIFTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO BY ELEVEN YOU
ARE OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DIANE-
I'M A MEMBER OF C. A. M. P. C.
I'VE BEEN A MASSAGE THERAPIST
FOR FORTY SIX YEARS. AND ARE
YOU OPPOSED THE BILL AND LAST
THE BILL AS AMENDED TO BE
AUTHORIZED C. A. M. P. C. GOOD
FOR YEARS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS HOPEFULLY BUT THIS
IS IN SUPPORT PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE WILL ALIGN SEVENTY NINE YOU
ARE OPEN. HI I AM SENTENCING
GET OUT OF HIS SEAT AND ALSO ON
YOUR TIE AND FINANCIAL
INFORMATION UP AMERICA AND NINE
MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED MEMBERS.
WE APPLAUD. THE BEAUTIES- I
MEANT IT TO NEW YORK AND- WE
OUGHT TO LIVE. IN PEACE THE.
FOLLOWING YEAR THANK YOU. THE
YOU. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DIANE
HUBBARD ON THE CHEAP TREATMENT
AUTHOR FOR BURKE WILLIAMS WE
EMPLOY ALMOST A THOUSAND
MASSAGE THERAPIST WE ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS IT'S BILL IS
AMENDED TO RE AUTHORIZE. NEXT
PLEASE FIND TWENTY THANK YOU
WHY TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM KATHLEEN MICKEY ON BEHALF
OF OVER THREE THOUSAND GRADUATE
VEHICLES UNLESS THE BILL IS THE
POPE AMENDED TO RE AUTHORIZE
THE A. M. C. C. FOR FOUR YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
AND AS A REMINDER OF THIS IS
WE'RE SHOWING SUPPORT NOW FOR
A. B. FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY SEVEN MY
NINETY SEVEN YEAR OLD. GOOD
MORNING JAMIE SHOT BACK ON
BEHALF OF PRECISION NAILS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. BY NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NINETY NINE
ARE YOU MUTED. ONE MORE TRY.
I'M SORRY CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER
SO HE COULD GET THEM TO FOCUS
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN THOUGHT
THEIR P. THIRTY AT THE LOCATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT. FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR OPEN
PLEASE ON MUTE. WELL BEING
ONLINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
RESPONSE WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SIX. THIS IS RON
SIDEMEN PRESIDENTFIVE BRANCHES
UNIVERSITY AND WE ARE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
PLEASE. LINE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
INTERESTED IN YOUR HOME WELL
I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF THE TRENDY
TROUBLE COME THIS TIME THAT WE
OPPOSE A NATIONAL IS AMENDED TO
WE ARE PRICED G. AND PC FOR
FOUR YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. LINE FORTY
NINE YOUR OLD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN VAN IN THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PROGRAM COORDINATOR
FOR SAN MATEO COUNTY OUR
PROGRAM IS HOUSED WITHIN THE
SAME IN HILL COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
UNLESS THIS IS AMENDED TO RE
AUTHORIZE CNPC FOR ANOTHER FOUR
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
NEXT PLEASE LINE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I AM A
DOCTOR BENJAMIN SOME DIRECT
BILL CALIFORNIA MOST OFTEN
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF OUR
THIRTY PLUS MEMBERS SCHOOLS WE
OPPOSE AND LET THE MANDATE TO
REALTOR RIGHT BNP PEOPLE FOR
YEARS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
PLEASE. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AV FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN POINT FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIFTY THREE YOU ARE
OPEN AGAIN. HELLO THIS IS ADAM
SCHIFF ALL YOU GIVE ME
PERFECTLY FULLY UNDERSTAND.
YEAH I WAS I WAS ALL ENOUGH
BUT- HE'LL BE KNOCKED UP IN SAN
DIEGO OR THEIR ON A CLOSER TO
CENTER AND- WE STRONGLY OPPOSE-
AND THAT'S THE- OUR MOTION
AMENDED SORT OF THE FOUR YEARS.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE HUNDRED ARE YOU REALLY.
WELL THE ONE WE WERE LINE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH PLEASE PROCEED. NEXT
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE
STILL OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
PROCEED. CAN YOU HEAR ME
PERFECTLY. I AM PLANNING A
MASSAGE THERAPIST FOR THIRTY
YEARS I HOPE THE BILL AND LET
THAT DEMANDED BY VIRTUE RE
AUTHORIZED C. A. M. P. C. FOR
ANOTHER FOUR YEARS THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. ADD UP MR WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE. OKAY
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS
AND OPPONENTS LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE JEFF
ROSEN AND DR STEPHANIE POWELL
PERHAPS ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY
IN A POSITION. AS A LEADER
OPPONENTS WITNESSES IF YOU WERE
ON THE LINE OR HERE PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM DOCTOR STEPHANIE
CALL THE NATIONAL CENTER ON
SEXUAL EXPLOITATION C. A. M. P.
C. IT'S EFFECTIVE IN ITS
COLLABORATIVE MANNER IN WHICH
THEY HELP THOSE OF US ON THE
FRONTLINE OF COMBAT IN HUMAN
SEX TRAFFICKING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. C. A. M. P. C. AS A
MODEL. OF HOW RELIABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE EDUCATIONAL
STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT ACTION
ESPECIALLY THIS OF CERTIFICATE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. THAT
WORKS AND EFFECTIVE OUT WE
CHECK IN THE MAIL THOSE WHO
EXPLOIT THE MOST VULNERABLE
SECONDLY I'M CONCERNED THAT THE
ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF C. A. M.
D. C. WILL BE A COST WITH
GREATER UNCERTAINTY. AND LACK
OF CLARITY BASED ON MY ACADEMIC
KNOWLEDGE MY DOCTOR IN
ORGANIZATIONAL LEADERSHIP
THAT'S TO TEACH A CLASS
REQUIRES LOOKING AHEAD SEVERAL
YEARS AND THE DELL RAISED BY
THIS BILL REGARDING THE NEW
FEATURE OF C. T. C. COULD PROVE
DEVASTATING. ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU CONSIDER CERTIFICATIONS FOR
THEIR PURPOSE IN SCHOOLS ARE
FOR TWO AND FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
YOUR EXTENSION AND THE THREAT
OF MASSIVE CHANGE IS DEEPLY
PROBLEMATIC. AT THE VERY LEAST
I WOULD HAVE SAID THE COMMITTEE
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON CMT C. TO
FOUR YEARS GIVE THEM THE TIME.
THEY NEED TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD I'M CYNICAL COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN I
LEAD THE LARGEST DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE NORTH OF LOS
ANGELES THERE ARE MANY THINGS
THAT ARE BROKEN IN OUR SOCIETY
AND NEED TO BE FIXED WHEN
SOMETHING IS NOT BROKEN DON'T
FIX IT. IDON'T UNDERSTAND THE
LOGIC OF REPLACING AN ENTITY
LIKE C. M. T. C. WITH THE DCA
LICENSING BOARD THAT IS
EXPENSIVE ON WE OWN THE
BUREAUCRATIC AND WE'LL PROVE
INEFFECTIVE MY BIGGER CONCERN
THIS MORNING IS THAT EXTENDING
THE SUNSET DATE FOR ONLY ONE
YEAR IS A DAMAGING PERHAPS
CRIPPLING DECISION. THE CFTC
CERTIFICATION FOR THERAPIST IS
FOR TWO YEARS THOSE WHO ARE DUE
TO RENEW ONE QUESTION WHY AS
WITH THOSE WHO ARE NEW MASSAGE
SCHOOLS HAVE HAD A CRIPPLING
COLVIN YEAR THEIR CERTIFICATION
IS FOR FOUR YEARS THEY WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE. CFD HAS BEEN A STRONG
AND EFFECTIVE PARTNER AGAINST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
PROSTITUTION AND ILLICIT
MASSAGE BUSINESSES. IN SANTA
CLARA AND SAN MATEO COUNTIES
CMT C. IS HELP TO CLOSE
HUNDREDS OF ILLICIT MASSAGE
BUSINESSES WERE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND PROSTITUTION
WERE RAMPANT. CMT C. IS CLEANED
UP AND RAISE THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF MASSAGE
THERAPY ALL OVER CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS WHY ASDISTRICT
ATTORNEY I WANT TO EXPAND AND
EXTEND MY MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH MT C.
BECAUSE C. M. D. C. HAS BEEN SO
EFFECTIVE. AND HOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHE DOWN. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING ORGANISED. AND HELP
HUMANS. VICTIMS THE TYPE SENSOR
PER MADE THAT MUCH MORE TO. CMT
C. IS A LETTER. SIX STORY I
NIMBLE AFFECT LOW OR- THAT IS
ENOUGH FOR AN IMPORTANT IN
FIGHT AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND LIFTING UP AND HELP HUMAN.
VICTIMS WHEN SOMETHING IS
WORKING AND WORKING WELL LEAVE
IT ALONE. VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
OR AMENDED TO RE AUTHORIZE CMT
C. FOR ANOTHER FOUR YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LET'S MOVE TO
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF PLEASE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL I'M SURE NOW WITH THE
SOUTH BAY COALITION TO END
HUMAN TRAFFICKING ON BEHALF OF
OUR MEMBER AGENCIES INCLUDING
ASIAN AMERICANS FOR COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT COMMUNITY SOLUTIONS
LOVE NEVER FAILS THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WAGED UP COALITION
SISTER HOLY NAME JESUS AND MARY
SISTER OF THE BLESSED VIRGIN
MARY AND THE TAKFIRI JUSTICE
CENTER. WE OPPOSE UNLESS THE
BILL AS AMENDED TO RE AUTHORIZE
HIM TO SEE FOR FOUR YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY CONCERN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL MASSAGE THERAPY
COALITION- WE REPRESENT MOST OF
THE LEADING PROVIDERS OF
MASSAGE IN THE STATE. AND WE'RE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED- AND THE
INTERVAL FOR THE SUNSET IS
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS STACY TO
ACQUIRE AND I'M A MASSAGE
THERAPIST OF TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
AND THEN A MTA MEMBER. SIMILAR
TO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS
THE STREET STATE I STRONGLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THIS
BILL AND PLEASE GIVE IT A FIVE
YEAR EXTENSION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
ONE. TWELVE WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
SEVEN SAYING NO WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR SHARED
EXPRESSED OPPOSITION FOR AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL LINE EIGHTY THREE.
EIGHTY THREE ARE OWNED BY. I
YES I AM NOT MY NAME IS LINDA
CURRENT TIME PRESIDENT OF
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN SAN FRANCISCO SECTION AND
WE WORK IN COLLABORATION- WITH
SAN FRANCISCO COLLABORATIVE
AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING HI
I'M CALLING TO UPHOLD- AND
THREE FEET AT FIVE SEVEN- AND
AT LEAST ASKING- THAT'D BE
AMENDED- I HAD TO EXTEND IT SUN
SAID TO- FOR FIVE YEARS- WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT- I SEE A M.
HE HE AND THE IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT THEY DO I ESPECIALLY
SUPPORTED AS A- RETIRED TO A
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
COUNSELOR WORKING WITH HUNDREDS
OF- MASSAGE THERAPIST- IN
TRAINING OR NEEDING TO CHANGE
JOBS DUE TO DISABILITY AND I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT. C. A. M. P.
IS FOR- YOUR AVAILABLE. SERVICE
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT PLEASE.
HOLD THE LINE ONE OH TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
TONY PSYCHO THIS I'M A
CERTIFIED MASSAGE THERAPIST AND
A MEMBER OF A. IN TA. I OPPOSE
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
UNLESS AMENDED TO RE AUTHORIZE
FURY IN PC FOR AT LEAST FOUR
YEARS THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. HI
MODEL FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
AM BETTER CAROLINE J. A
CONSTITUENT OF I'VE BEEN LOVING
THE THOUGHT EXPERIMENT FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS I OPPOSE
UNLESS MR LOWE AMEND HIS BILL
AND RE AUTHORIZES THE NPC FOR
FOUR YEARS THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. BY NINETEEN EUROPE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN ARE
YOU MUTED. SECONDLY RIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY NINETEEN.
I'M MOVING ALONG OVER LINE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME'S DIVIDES. PRESIDENT
NATIONAL INSTITUTE. THIS YEAH.
SHE MIGHT RUN FOR BE ALLOWED TO
MONITOR FOUR PLUS YEARS THANKS
THANK YOU YOUR NEXT BILL IS.
ONE HUNDRED YOUR OPEN. ONE ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE ON MUTE. LINE
ONE HUNDRED ONE MORE CHANCE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AUDREY WITH HIGH
CHECK ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO
COUNTY- THE COUNTY OF SAN MATEO
OPPOSES UNLESS THE BUILDING
MANAGER WE AUTHORIZE THE PA AND
PC FOR FOUR YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SIX
SEVENTEEN YOUR OPEN. HELLO WE
CAN HEAR YOU YES PERFECTLY
PLEASE PROCEED NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. MY NAME IS JUDY
TELFORD WITH THE HELP FROM
TRADERS CO CREATION AND
NATIONAL FELLOWSHIP WORKING
SESSIONS WITH MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS WE
OPPOSE THE LEFT FIELD
COMMANDERS TO READ OFF THE RUN.
SIXTEEN FOR FOUR YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. I
MISSED CARE NO MORE FOR IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. FINE LET'S
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
CALLINGS ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
OR CONCERNS. SENATOR BOOKER. I
THINK WE WE'VE HEARD STRONGLY
FROM THE DA ROSE AND I ALSO
HEARD FROM MY COUNTY MANAGER
CEMETERY COUNTY MY KALECKI WHO
WAS THIS VERY SKEPTICAL C. MTZ
CMT CNN HAS NOW THAT WAS PUT ON
THE BOARD FOR EIGHT YEARS HE'S
A FORMER POLICE CHIEF AND HE
SPEAKS BOTH OF THEM I'M
INCREDIBLY STRONGLY ABOUTTHEIR
EFFORTS TO CUT DOWN ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND CERTAINLY
THERE'S THE CONCERNS ON BOTH
THEIR PARTS THAT. WITHOUT SEEM
TO SEE. TIME WITHOUT A LONGER
WE AUTHORIZATION THAT WE COULD
TAKE A STEP BACK AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SO. THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND IS
SOMETHING I WILL CERTAINLY BE
LOOKING AT. AS WE MAKE THIS
DECISION GOING FORWARD ABOUT
WHAT TO DO WITH HIM TO SEE
VERSUS. MOVING TO A LICENSURE
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR IS CAN WE CONSIDER
SOMETHING SAY TWO YEARS BECAUSE
THIS ARGUMENT THAT.
CERTIFICATES FOR TWO YEARS AND
THAT WE CAN. THEN EXTEND. A MAN
IS CONCERNED THAT ONE YEAR THEN
MAKES THE- CAN EXISTING REGIME
LESS EFFECTIVE- AND THE IF
THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE WE MAY ASK
YOU BUT THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ONE YEAR IS
JUST AN EXTENSION SO WE HAVE
WORK TO DO- AND CERTAINLY WILL
BE MY PRIORITY DURING THAT YEAR
TO A FIGURE OUT OF TIME IF WE
CAN MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
EFFORTS COMBATING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING WHICH AGAIN I HEAR
FROM MY FOLKS ARE VERY
EFFECTIVE SO I JUST ADD ANY
COMMENTS ON ANY OF THAT. HELLO
YES THE CHAIR IF I MIGHT- THANK
YOU SENATOR BAKER AS YOU RECALL
FROM OUR SONS AT HEARINGS.
WHICH WE HAD A FULL AMOUNT OF
DISCUSSION. ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES TO BE IRONED OUT DUE TO
THE CORPORATE PANDEMIC. WE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAD A
FULL BREADTH OF. EXPERIENCE
DIVING INTO THESE ISSUES AND
IRON OUT THESE ISSUES WE ALSO.
AS YOU WELL KNOW. AS CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS AND WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR HERE IN THE SENATE.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
THERE'S CONSISTENCY. IN BOTH
HOUSES AND WE WISH AND DESIRE
TO HAVE MORE TIME TO I KNOW
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WHICH IS
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU. A NO
VOTE TODAY WOULD ELIMINATE THE
BOARD- ELIMINATE THAT COUNTS I
SHOULD SAY EXCUSE ME. TO JUST
BE VERY CLEAR. A NO VOTE TODAY
WOULD. ELIMINATE THE COUNCIL
WHICH WOULD THEN GIVE.
ARGUMENTS TO THAT OF A
POTENTIAL SUNRISE AND CREATION
OF A NEW ENTITY SO- I JUST WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR TO. HELP
ENSURE THAT WE CLEAR THAT UP
WITH ADVOCATES AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO ENSURE. WHAT
ARE YES AND NO VOTE SIGNIFIES
TODAY. JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE- DONE ABOUT
FIFTEEN OR SIXTEEN BOARDS AND
BUREAUS IN THE SUNSET REVIEW
PERIOD OF MY NUMBER IS CORRECT
BECAUSE OF THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND THE IMPACT ON THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY IN OUR
LEGISLATIVE SESSION IN THE
RESTRICTED NUMBER OF HEARINGS
THAT WE COULD CONDUCT OVER THE
LAST OF FIFTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. OF THE ISSUE HERE HAS
TO DO WITH WHETHER TO ALLOW THE
COUNCIL TO CONTINUE. IT'S A
VERY VERY GOOD WORK OR WHETHER
THERE IS ANY BENEFIT TO BE
DERIVED FROM ESTABLISHING YET
ANOTHER. BORDER BUREAU TO
HANDLE THIS THERE THE-
UNDOUBTEDLY WILL BE A LIVELY
CONVERSATION WHEN WE GET TO
THAT WE DID NOT HAVE THE TIME
TO. ENGAGE FULLY IN THAT
CONVERSATION THIS YEAR
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE
SCHEDULE AND THE OTHER ISSUE
FRANKLY. IS THE COST TO THE
LICENSEES OF ESTABLISHING
ANOTHER BORDER BUREAU TO HANDLE
THIS BECAUSE IF YOU KNOW. THESE
ARE SPECIAL FUND FUNDED BOARDS
AND BUREAUS WHICH MEANS THE
PEOPLE THAT WE CHOOSE TO
REGULATE ARE FORCED TO PAY THE
FEES TO OPERATE THE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS. SO AS I'VE
COMMUNICATED TO- CHAIR LOW IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE DO
A RATHER DETAILED FINANCIAL
PROJECTIONS AND WE PASS THAT
INFORMATION ON. TO THOSE
LICENSEES WHO SEEM VERY
INTERESTED IN HAVING A STATE
BORDER BUREAU- AS OPPOSED TO
THE CURRENT ARRANGEMENT THERE'S
NO. INTENT TO END- THIS.
ORGANIZATION ONE FORM OR
ANOTHER THAT'S CONTRIBUTED SO
MIGHTILY TO THE ISSUES THAT ARE
OF INTEREST TO THE THOSE OF YOU
IN YOUR DISTRICT SO I JUST
WANTED TO ADD THAT TO- TO SORT
OF SUPPLEMENT WHAT SURE LOVE
SAID WITH REGARD TO THIS
MEASURE. CENTER BECKER. A
CLARIFICATION AND THAT'S WHAT
I'VE BEEN SAYING TO THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT. IF WE VOTE YES ON
THIS TODAY DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE
GETTING RID OF C. M. T. C. AND
AGAIN JUST PICKING FOR MYSELF
FOR SO I SHOULD SAY. I AM I MET
PERSONALLY A HUGE BELIEVER
MASSAGE THERAPY HAVE BENEFITED
FOR TREMENDOUSLY SO I'VE
TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR. THE
FOLKS ARE PRACTICING A MASSAGE
THERAPY AND- BUT I JUST WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT YOU GET IF
WE DO VOTE YES THAT IN THIS
YEAR- WE'LL BE LOOKING TO. OUT
ALSO AND LOOKING TO- MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN. THAT WE EITHER WE
CONTINUE IT OR WE CERTAINLY
LOOK AT THE BENEFITS THAT THE
WORK THE CMT C. IS BEEN DOING
ON THE ON THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
FRAUD. AND MAKE SURE WE DON'T
TAKE TWO STEPS BACKWARD THANK
YOU ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SIR.
SATURDAY YES- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM US SENATOR
BACKER. I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
HIM AND HEAR THE DA- FROM SANTA
CLARA WHO I HAVE. MET SOME OUT
OF RESPECT FOR MISTER ROSEN- I
HOPE AS WE WORK IN THE FUTURE
WE CAN- YEAH I'D I'D PUT. THE
WEEKEND- YOUR FIX THESE ISSUES
AND- I WILL- ADDED DEFERENCE TO
OUR CHAIR CREATURE- IN THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTRE BATES. I THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO CONCUR WITH MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM NOW ON NOT THE
LEADERSHIP THAT OUR OUR CHEERS
OF THE BNP AWESOME REMEMBER LOW
AND NOW SENATOR ROTH- DOWN THE
TIGHT SCHEDULE WE HAD THIS YEAR
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BUT- I THINK THAT THE COMMENTS
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT OR VERY
VERY COMPELLING IN TERMS OF
THEIR ABILITY TO INTERACT. WITH
THE COUNCIL AND SOMETIMES THE
BUREAUCRACY CAN BE AN
IMPEDIMENT TO GETTING THAT KIND
OF INTERACTION THAT KIND OF
WORK IN INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES
SO I HOPE THAT THE BULLS
FORWARD NEXT YEAR I'LL TAKE A-
DEEPER DIVE INTO A CLOSE LOOK
AT THAT AND HEAR MORE FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE IT'S ALL
ABOUT. SEX TRAFFICKING IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE GROUPS
BEING ABLE TO INTERCEDE AN
INTERCEPT ON NORTH COBB THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU
CENTER YOU CAN COUNT ON US
DOING A DEEPER DIVE. COLLEAGUES
ANY FURTHER. COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NONE. SOME
REMEMBER LOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
GERMAN ROSS- CALLING TO AGAIN
THIS IS. ONE OF SIXTEEN BOARDS
BUREAUS COUNCILS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TO DO THAT. SEVEN
SEVEN. REVIEW PROCESS. I KNOW
MANY OF YOU HAVE ATTENDED SOME
OF OUR INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS
AS WELL AND PUT YOUR TIE AND
DILIGENCE. YOU'LL BE REST
ASSURED TO KNOW THAT SHARE RAFA
NINE SIX HAVE A DEEP COMMITMENT
TO IRON OUT MANY OF THESE
ISSUES INCLUDING THAT OF.
MASSAGE THERAPY COUNSEL WITH
RESPECT I ASKED FOR A VOTE IN
EXTENDING. THE COUNCIL FOR
ADDITIONAL YEAR SO WE CAN
FURTHER IRON OUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU SIR MAY I HAVE A
MOTION PLEASE. MOVED BY SENATOR
MAN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVEN A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY SEVEN T.
PROCESSOR THE SENATE FLOOR
RALPH HI ROSS I'M MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA EYED PEAS
EATS I BACKER BACKER I'D DODD
DOT I EXAMINE A MAN I HER TADO.
HER TADO I'D JONES JONES I.
LEIVA LEAVE THE ICEMAN MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEW MAN I A CHILL ABODE.
BUT SURE VOGUE I PAN CAN I.
BILL AS THIRTEEN VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE ROLE OPEN FOR ANY
APPS AND MEMBERS. NEXT IS FILE
IT OF NUMBER EIGHT A. B. ONE
FIVE THREE TWO. NURSING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR OR
FIVE MORE TO GO OUR SPECIALLY
PRESENTED ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY TWO WHICH EXTENDS THE
SENSOR'S BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING AND I'D LKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE MINUTES AND THEN
ALICE'S EXTENDING THE BOARD AND
CORPORATE NINETEEN PROVISIONS
FIVE ONE YEAR RESPECTFULLY ASKS
FOR I VOTED AND ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FONG AND
DOLLY- ON THE CONVERSATIONS
REGARDING LICENSING TIME LINES
ON THE LINE FOR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT IS OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. THIS
LORETTA MELBY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. OKAY AND SINCE MRS
MEL B. IS ON THE LINE FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. IF I
UNDERSTAND THAT CORRECTLY MR
LOW WILL MOVE TO ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. I SEE
NO WITNESSES WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIVE THREE TWO ROOM ONE TWELVE
SITTING NONE. LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES PUSHING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICED BY WRITER IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
TWO WE WILL PROCEED. THANK YOU
MUCH TERRIBLY EXPRESS BOARD FOR
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO
PLEASE PESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY
ZERO THREE FIVE SUPPORT AT.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO. AND WE HAVE
NO PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME. OKAY BY THE WAY I
MISSED MY READY I DON'T HEAR
YOU VERY CLEARLY SO YOU MAY
HAVE TO SPEAK UP. LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IS THAT BETTER
YEAH IT IS MUCH BETTER. LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION FIRST
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO SUCH
WITNESSES WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SAYING LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE ONCE
AGAIN I MISSED MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FIVE THREE TWO WILL PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIR YES I APOLOGIZE I
WAS ON MUTE- JUST TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE PRACTICED THE QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. EVERYBODY
THANK YOU EVERYBODY ELSE GOING
AT ONE ZERO. ONE ONE OH NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT ONE ONE
NINE IF YOU COULD PUT YOURSELF
OUT IF YOU HIT ONE ZERO AGAIN.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION ONE OH NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. I NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU BUT- LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS MEASURE. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR LEVINSON REMEMBER
LOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SEXY **** RIVAL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO DEEP PASSES
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RAW. ROSS I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
IBEATS BEATS HI BACKER. BACKER
I. DODD. DOT I A MAN A MAN I
HER TADO. JONES JONES I. LEIVA
LEVI MAN MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN I
H. O. ABOGADOS UNTIL ABOUT IPN.
CAN I BILL OF TWELVE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ANY
ABSENT MEMBERS VIOLATED NUMBER
NINE MR LOW YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR NEXT COMMITTEE BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RESEARCHER AND COLLEAGUES AGAIN
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REFLECTED IN ALICE'S
ON THE SUNSET FOR THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY. AS YOU KNOW WITH IT
WE'VE ADDRESSED MANY OF THESE
ISSUES DISCUSSED AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING THAT WE HAD BACK IN
NOVEMBER I AGAIN WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN RALPH AND A COMMITTEE
STAFFER COOPERATION. IN THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU IS SIMPLY MEMBER LOW I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY AND PERHAPS YOU HAVE
C. W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL ON
THE LINE. IF SO WITNESSES
PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRPERSON ROTH AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY I'DLIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
CONSIDERATION AND WH IT
SUPPORT. AND REPORT IN THE
IDENTIFIED ISSUES. I FIND THAT
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS IN AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE ACCORDING.
TO THE COURT THE COURT
CONVICTION CHIN AN INCLUSION OF
THE POLICY CHANGES I'D BE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING K. MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JACKIE GRANDMA LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR YES HE DOESN'T. I'M
HERE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE ON
BEHALF OF A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS CALIFORNIA
SEVERAL THOUSAND OF THEM ARE
PHARMACISTS AND PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO THANK CHAIRMAN ROB SHERMAN
LOW AND THAT'S EXACTLY IN
SENATE COMMITTEE CANFOCUS FOR
ALL THEIR WORK ON THAT THERE'S
FOUR DIFFERENT INDEPENDENT
RADIO WELL YOU COULD HAVE USED
RECORDED ON THE MANY COMPONENTS
AND EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE
I'M GOING TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS
ON THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL.
THAT FOCUS ON ENFORCEMENT A
FINANCIAL PENALTY MUST BE
CONSEQUENTIAL ENOUGH TO DISPLAY
THE CONTACT AT THE TEMPLE
HOWEVER THE MAXIMUM FINE THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY CAN IMPOSE ON
LARGE CORPORATE PHARMACIES FOR
PATIENT I MEANCONTACT IT'S
SIMPLY THAT IT'S SIMPLY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. PER SECOND
SECOND HALF THE LIMIT AND SMALL
CLAIMS COURT NEEDLESS TO SAY
THAT'S EXTREMELY SMALL LEVEL OF
FINE DO NOT WORK TO PROMOTE
COMPLIANCE. FOR THE MARCH THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY IS LIMITED TO
FIGHTING EACH PHARMACY
INDIVIDUALLY MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO HOLD STORES UNDER
COMMON OWNERSHIP ACCOUNTABLE
AND TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY PROCTOR THREE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE THREE
BIGGEST RETAIL CHAIN FAILING TO
PROPERLY PROVIDE PERSONAL
CONSULTATIONS. AND PRESCRIPTION
DRUG THE PATIENT ALL THREE OF
THESE MAJOR RETAILERS WERE
ULTIMATELY FINED AND FORCED TO
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS FOR PATIENT
CONSULTATION YEAH ACCORDING TO
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
VIOLATIONS REGARDING PATIENT
COMPLICATIONS. CONTINUE TO
FIGHT PLAYSTATIONS ISSUED BY
THE BOARD AND FIND A SET FOR
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AT
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES
THE PROBLEM NOT QUITE BROADLY
ESTABLISHING HIGHER FINES FOR
SINGLE VIOLATIONS BY PERMITTING
HIGHER FINES ONLY FOR REPEATED
IN BRAZEN VIOLATION OF LAW
THANK YOU FOR THAT. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM NOT DYING.
OPPOSED AMENDMENT SIXTY. REDUCE
IT ABOUT. WE STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THE NEW. FOR WILL STILL
PROMOTE COMPLIANCE ASKING FOR.
LAWS WITH. FOR I DID NOT
COMPROMISE THAT WERE RE. CLOSE
A LINE FOR THE AVERAGE. TO CURE.
HELLO ELIMINATING. PENALTIES
FOR SECOND I DON'T FOR FREE VIA.
WE HIGHER. MAYBE IN. ANY
FURTHER MY MENTAL SO NOTHING
REDUCE THE AMOUNT TWENTY
AGAINST PATIENT CONTACT
OCCURRING COMMUNITY. HELLO.
ENFORCEMENT ACTION WITH THE
DISTRICT OF OFFICE ARE NOT
ALWAYS. THAT IS ENFORCEMENT IN
FIFTH THIRTY ARE NOT REALLY
NEED IT. TO PATIENTS IN FRONT
OF. AND IT'S FOR ALL THE THREE
ON EIGHTY FIFTH THIRTY THANK
YOU. FOR YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
YOUR ANY SOME WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SO NONE LET'S MOVE
WITNESS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
THREE SAYING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
THREE. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A B. ONE
FIVE THREE THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO INDEX
PRESS FOR FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE.
THAT'S ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL ALIGN EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JENNIFER
MALLEY- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO NINE EIGHTY NINE
YOU ARE OPEN. WE SHALL RETURN
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. THE FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. FOR FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE. AND WE HAVE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE JENNIFER
SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAIL ASSOCIATION
AND NATIONAL ASSOCIATION. OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES IN THE
GALLERY TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION MR PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- JENNIFER SNYDER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION. AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN
DRUG STORES. REGRETTABLY WE
MUST REMAIN OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE. WE'RE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET OF THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY PROVISIONS
INCLUDED IN SECTION FORTY THREE
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE OF THE
BILL. CONTINUE TO CAUSE A
STRONG CONCERNS. LET ME FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE AND EXPRESS- ARE.
REAL STRONG APPRECIATION FOR
THE AUTHOR TO HIS STAFF TO THE
COMMITTEE TO THE CHAIR- FOR
WORKING ON THIS LANGUAGE THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS AND THE AMENDMENTS
BEING OFFERED TODAY IN
COMMITTEE. TO ADDRESS MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE RAISED WITH
THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE. THE
SECTION FORTY THREE SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD GRANT UNPRECEDENTED
AUTHORITY. TO THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY WHICH ALLOWS FOR THEM
TO LEVY SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES
ON PHARMACIES THAT ARE UNDER
COMMON OWNERSHIP OR MANAGEMENT.
THE BILL PROPOSES TO INCREASE
THOSE FINES UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
CURRENTLY PHARMACIES CAN
RECEIVE UP TO ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A
VIOLATION. WELL THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS AS IT KNOWLEDGE TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE RIGHT TO
CURE A CERTAIN CRITERIA FOR THE
ASSESSMENT FOR THE BOARD- PRIOR
TO ISSUING THE PENALTIES WHICH
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE. WE
STILL BELIEVE THE AMOUNTS OF
THE EXTREME OF THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ARE FAR
TOO SEVERE. A RETAIL FOR RETAIL
PHARMACIES PROFIT MARGINS ARE
ACTUALLY VERY LOW ON AVERAGE
PHARMACIES HAVE LESS THAN A 2%
PROFIT MARGIN NATIONWIDE. SOME
OF OUR PHARMACIES ACTUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND LOST REVENUE IN
TWENTY TWENTY. WE DON'T KNOW OF
ANY OTHER STATE WHOSE BOARD OF
PHARMACY WILL BE GRANTS HAS
THIS AUTHORITY OR IS WILL BE
GRANTED THIS AUTHORITY. NOR ANY
OTHER STATE THAT COMES CLOSE TO
THESE TYPES OF FINE LEVELS. WE
DO HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR THE
COMMITTEE AND THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US ON THE SENSIBILITY TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AGAIN WHAT
WE DO APPRECIATE THE TIME SPENT
ON THESE AMENDMENTS- IN THE
PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN MADE. WE
MUST STILL POSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE LET'S ROOM
THAT'S MOVED TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. TO SEE IF THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
THERE THERE ARE NONE LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITED
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
THREE. WE WILL MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU TO OUR WEBSITE AND
APP LISTEN TO ABC FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. ONE ZERO
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. TO
FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE. AND WE
HAVE NO PARTICIPANTS QUEUING
UP. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE BACK TO THE CHAMBERS
TO MY COLLEAGUE'S QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS STARTING WITH
SENATOR DODD. MISTER CHAIR I
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE- A
COUPLE POINTS THE BILL TO THE
AUTHOR IF THAT'S OKAY. PLEASE
PROCEED SO- THE FIRST SPEAKER
BROUGHT OUT THAT THERE WERE
SOME THINGS THAT- THE
PHARMACIES WERE DOING AND I
THINK IT WAS CONSULTATION OR
NOT DOING THE PROPRIOCEPTIVE
TATIAN. BUT IT WAS KIND OF
GARBLED SO I DIDN'T REALLY GET
THAT VERY CLEAR SO COUPLE
THINGS I WANT TO UNDERSTAND IS
WHAT ARE THE TYPES OF BEHAVIORS
THAT ARE HAPPENING. THAT WERE
TRYING TO. STOP THOSE BEHAVIORS
AND WERE USING THESE FIGHTS AS
A MORE- PERHAPS APPROPRIATE WAY
OF DEALING WITH THEM AND
GETTING. YOU KNOW GETTING
COMPLIANCE AND THEN SECOND. I
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME THAT WE
GO FROM FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IT WAS GONNA BE A MILLION SO I
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN DOWN TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. BUT IT STILL SEEMS TO
ME THAT FROM 500-022-0050
THOUSAND- IS EXCESSIVE SO I
WONDER IF- ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOVE
YOU CAN ADDRESS THOSE COMMENTS
PLEASE. YES TO THE CHAIR IF I
IF I MIGHT ON THE ON THE ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY ON THE FINES. AS
YOU KNOW THAT. MANY
CALIFORNIANS GET MANY OF THE
DAY- SEPT MUCH OF THE SUPPORT
FROM SMALL TO SMALL INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES VERSUS THAT OF
RETAIL CHAINS AS WELL. AND A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR A FIVE
THOUSAND FINE APPLIES TO BOTH
THE INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES AS
WELL AS THE MAJOR CHAINS AS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
PARITY TO ENSURE THAT THIS THAT
BEFORE SMITH'S. MECHANISM
TOWARDS THAT ALSO IT WAS A
REFERENCE ABOUT THIS FINDING
UNPRECEDENTED. AS MEMBERS WILL
KNOW UNDER THIS COMMITTEE AT
THE ERROR OF JURISDICTION
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY CAN BRING
UP. TO A MILLION DOLLARS IN
FINES SPECIFICALLY SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT OF THE
COMPARISONS WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE. BUT
PERHAPS ALSO THE WITNESS FROM A
U. S. E. W. CAN ALSO SPEAK TO
SOME OF THE VIOLATIONS OF
EXPERIENCES THERE FRONT AND
CENTER. SHOULD YOU DESIRE TO
HEAR FROM THE. C. W. WITNESS IF
YOU'RE STILL ON THE LINE COULD
YOU ADDRESS MR CENTER DUDS
QUESTION. YEAH HAPPY TAIL
ACCENTOR GUARD. MY COMMENT. THE.
EIGHTY THOUSAND ELEVEN FINE-
AROUND. LAST COMPLICATIONS FROM
MEDICATION- WE RECENTLY PASSED
A BILL AT THE FOURTEEN FORTY
TWO BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
GOT A BOARD OF PHARMACY
REGULATIONS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND THE PURPOSE OF THAT BILL IF
YOU GET IT OUT THE PARK STAFF
DEPARTMENT THAT YOU ARE WORKING
BY THEMSELVES GETTING ALL THEIR
LIFE. MY COMPUTER USER PHARMACY
TECHNICIAN DUTIES AS WELL AS
NON LIFE AND BEAUTY LIKE
RINGING UP GROCERIES OR ON
HELPING PATIENTS FIND OVER THE
COUNTER MEDICINE AND- THAT
THEY'LL CONTINUE TO GO
UNENFORCED PHARMACISTS ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK. BY
THEMSELVES WITHOUT THE ADEQUATE
BUT AT HALF THE PART THAT THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO ALL OF
THEIR DUTIES- PROTECT PATIENT
TIME AND SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE
SAYING I'M HAPPY TO GO INTO
FURTHER ISSUES AROUND PATIENT
HUNTING CONTACT THAT. WE CAN
AND COMMUNITY PARTNERS. THIRTY
OKAY KELLY ANY OTHER QUESTION
COME. FOR CONCERNS. SEEING NONE
SEVEN MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I STRICTLY AFRICAN WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FIVE THREE THREE MOTION BY
SENATOR LEYVA. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NINE AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY THREE DEEP PASSES
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDMENT
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ROTH. ROTH IRA
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
IBEATS. BECKER BACKER I. DODD
DODD HI AIKMAN EGGMAN I. HER
TADO. JONES JONES I. LEIVA
LEAVE MEN MEN HI MY NAME IN.
NEWMAN I UNTIL A BOGEY. CAN CAN
I. BILL HAS TEN VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER
TEN A. B. ONE FIVE THREE FOUR
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY HELLO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THIS IS THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY SUNSET AND
WE CONTINUE WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO IRON OUT
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL. AND
WORKING TO MAKE THE NECESSARY
CLARIFICATIONS OF INTENT AS THE
BILL WHOSE ORDER RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. SIR MY NOTES
INDICATE THAT THE SHURA MURPHY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD
OF OPTOMETRY MAY BE ON THE LINE
DO YOU ANTICIPATE HE WILL
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. MS MURPHY
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SHARE- JUST THAT I THANK
YOU FOR THE CONTINUED
OPPORTUNITY TO YOU- THE STAFF
MANAGEMENT BOARDS AND SHE
REALLY- GET THE BOARDING
pOPPORTUNITY TO- AND THEN
ACTUALLY THE FOLEY- OVERSEES.
THE BACKDROP TO SHRINK. THANK
YOU LET'S TURN TO SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIVE THREE FOUR SEEING NONE.
LET'S MOVE THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE WE WILL BEGIN.
EVEN IF YOU'RE- NOT ONE MOMENT
THERE'S A BETTER THANK YOU MUCH
CARE FOR ARTISTS EXPRESS
SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR. AND
WE WILL GO TO WINE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIXTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
JAMES JACK REPRESENTING
NATIONAL VISION- WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE SUNSET EXTENSION
BUT AT THE DALLAS NOTES THERE
ARE STILL SOME DRAFTING ISSUES
IN THE BILL THAT REMAIN OF
CONCERN- BUT THAT SAID WE WILL
BE WORKING WITH THE EXCELLENT
STAFF FROM BOTH COMMITTEES THE
BOARD. AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
RESOLVE THESE CONCERNS OVER THE
BREAK AND HELP TO MOVE TO A
FULL SUPPORT POSITIONBY THE
BILLS NEXT YEAR THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR. ANALYZED
ONE AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THOMAS SHERMAN NUMBERS IT'LL
SLOW PUBLIC SMARTPHONE RPG
COMPANIES. IN SUPPORT COMMANDER
BEFORE WE CONCUR WITH MISTER
JACKSON MISS WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
STAFF IN THE OFFICE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. SURE
WE HAVE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP THANK YOU LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS WITH
REGARD TO ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES BEGINNING WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SAYING NO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY OR THEN ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIVE THREE
FOUR. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WITH
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE WILL
PROCEED. EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR. AND NOBODY
IS GIVING UP THE STRUCTURE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE CENTER LABOR HAS
MOVED THE BILL STILL REMEMBER
LOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HIGHLIGHTING TEN AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY FOUR DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH. ROSS I
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
IBEATS. BEATS BY BECKER BECKER
I DAUGHTER. DONNA HI AIKMAN
EIGHT MEN I HER TADO. JONES
JONES I. LEIVA LEAVE ICEMAN MAN
HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I A CHILL
ABODE UNTIL ABOUT FIVE PM CAN I.
THOSE TWELVE VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. FILE ITEM ELEVEN A. B.
ONE FIVE THREE FIVE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD HELLO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN CALLING
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE THE SENSE OF
VEHICLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO ALSO ATTENDED THE
SUNSET OVERSIGHT HEARING FOR
THAT BOARD ON MARCH THIRD TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. AND MY
NOTES REFLECT THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD IS ON
THE LINE. YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING THE MEMBER MY NAME IS
JESSICA SUPERMAN AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD MY
COURT THE COURT TV FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK AND
COLLABORATION ON THE BILL AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
ACT THING IN ACTED. IMPROVE
PROFIT AFRICAN PLACES THESE
CONSUMERS CAN OVERALL BOARD
OPERATION THE BOARD FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS EVALUATING IT
STATUTES AND REGULATIONS TO
ELIMINATE UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
TO LICENSURE STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS AND IMPROVE CONSUMER
PROTECTION MECHANISMS BUILT
INCLUDES THE PRODUCT IN THAT IN
THAT THREE DS. WE BELIEVE THAT
BILL WILL IMPROVE HOW WE START
TO THINK WORDS ARE WRITTEN TO
YOU CAN'T SEE COLORS AND YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM NO SIR. FOR MANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SAYING NO SO WITNESS ARE THERE
ANY WINDOWS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
TO. AND OF. BILL ONE FIVE
THREE. SITTING WITH SOME TO THE
TOP. SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT.
INDIVIDUALS WE IN TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIVE THREE FIVE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU BYE TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR A. B. THIRTEEN R. C. THE
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A.
B. E. FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE. ONE
MOMENT IS THE PARTICIPANTS YOU
ARE PLEASE. AND WE WILL BEGIN
WITH ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI KAREN I'M THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL WELFARE
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INCLUDING LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THAT WILL INSURE SHELTERS
OPEN VETERINARIAN ARE STILL
ABLE TO PROVIDE PROMPT AN
IMPORTANT CARE FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE. HOMELESS ANIMALS
RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS THAT
THE FACULTY AND ARE EXTREMELY
DIVERSE STATE WHERE REPORTERS
ARE SEVERELY LIMITED IN THE
AREA. THE WONDERFUL MOVED TO
PROTECT THE ANIMALS IN OUR CARE
IT'S A HUGE THING FOR THE HARD
WORKING STAFF AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE REMEMBER NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. WE WILL I SIXTY GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SUSAN RIGGS
REPRESENTING THE ASPCA I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY- WE ARE CURRENTLY
NEUTRAL THAT'LL HAPPEN CONCERNS
I'D LIKE TO RAISE. A BIRTHDAY
LETTER ADDRESSED THE ISSUES
RAISED IN THE FRONT BACKGROUND
PAPER RELATED TO USE OF
TELEMEDICINE THE ASPCA HAS
INVESTED ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME WORKING WITH THE B. AND B.
TELL THE SEDATE THAT NEGATIVE
IMPACT TO CALIFORNIANS AS A
RESULT OF THIS THE STATE HAVING
THE NATION'S MOST REGRET THAT.
A MEDIC MEDICINE REGULATION.
WELL THE COURT DID ACKNOWLEDGE
THE SHORT TERM IMPACT THE
CLIENT VETERINARY CARE DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE- INTERNET.
THOUSANDS OF RURAL AND LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE SEVERE CHALLENGES IN
ACCESSING CARE FOR THEIR
ANIMALS. AS A TEMPORARY WAIVERS
PROVIDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS EXPIRE
GEOGRAPHY WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AN INSURMOUNTABLE OBSTACLE TO
ENSURE THAT. ANIMAL DO NOT NEED
FOR NEEDLESSLY SUFFER.
TELEMEDICINE ISN'T AN
INVALUABLE TOOL TO BREED BRIDGE
THE BARRIERS TO CARE. THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ALSO BE
AWARE THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY
FIRST AMENDMENT CHALLENGES TO
STATE IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS ON
THAT NOW WE HAVE A MEDICINE. IN
THE FOURTH BEST NINE AND A LOT
OF FEDERAL CIRCUIT. MAY REQUIRE
THE STATE TO RECONSIDER ITS
CURRENT PARADIGM. WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE DIRECTION
TO THAT NEAR MEDICAL BOARD TO
EXPAND TELEMEDICINE BY
ELIMINATING THEM PERCENT.
REQUIREMENT FOR ESTABLISHING TO
BE CPR. DOING SO WILL
DRAMATICALLY. IMPROVE ACCESS TO
THAT NEED CARE. I JUST WANTED
TO. ADDRESS ANIMUS A QUICK AND
CURRENT FOR OF DELL ARE ANTI
TO. THE BILL FOR AN SHELTERS TO
GRAB MEDICAL OF ANNA THE NEXT.
WELL WE THAT THE- ARE. STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE CONCERNS THAT CURRENTLY
LANGUAGE PLACES UNREASONABLE
CONSTRAINT ON THE PROVISION OF
BETTER CARE. GIVEN THE
STATUTORY OBLIGATION IMPOSED ON
SHELTERS FOR NECESSARY AND
PROPER CARE. WE ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
HOW THESE MAIN OBLIGATION
CONFLICT WITH OPERATIONAL
CONSTRUCT IMPOSED BY THE DMV.
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. AND ACTUALLY THE LINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. HI AT
THREE THREE SHARE THE
GOVERNMENT AS A THERAPY THAT
THE ASIAN ON THE FIRST OF MANY
WE'RE DEEPLY DISCOURAGED
BECAUSE YOU DON'T AGREE BUT
THIS WAS NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
BILL WE SUPPORT THE COMMENDED%
WITH REQUESTED WITHIN THAT
TIMELINE THE REDUCED TO TWO
YEARS WITH DIRECT INTO THE
BOARD TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IDENTIFYING APPROPRIATE
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY AME IS
KAREN OUTLETS I AM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ANIMAL
PHYSICAL THERAPY COALITION- AND
I HAVE BEEN A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST IN THE STATE TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND SUCCESSFULLY
WORKING ON ANIMALS AFTER
RECEIVING TE APPROPRIATE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING- AND BEEN
DOING THAT FOR OVER THIRTEEN
YEARS. UNFORTUNATELY I AM HERE
AGAIN TO TESTIFY TO THE BOARD
YOU CAN YOU IN CONCERNING
CONTACT AS IT RELATES TO HOW
ANIMALS BUT THERE CAN'T BE AN
ALLEGED ISSUE HAS BEEN HANDLED
THE REGULATORY LANGUAGE THAT IS
IN IT CURRENTLY IN THE FINAL
STAGES WITH THE DCA WOULD BE
DETRIMENTAL AND HAVE A-
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL OWNERS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. I KNOW TO BELIEVE
CHERUB ROCK RETURNS ABOUT THE
ANIMAL REHABILITATION PT DURING
THE INITIAL CONTACT WAS NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE ANALYSIS
DESPITE IT BEING IDENTIFIED
HADN'T ISSUE IN BOTH THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE FRONT THAT. WE WOULD BE
MOVED TO THE PORT EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE BUT ONLY
WITH AMENDMENTS DOCUMENTED IN
THE LETTERS THAT WERE SENT OVER
THE WEEKEND AND THOSE WERE TO
PUT A HOLD ON THE CURRENT AND
HARMFUL ANIMAL REHAB REGULATORY
LANGUAGE IT'S A LEGISLATIVE
REMEDY IS THOUGHT TO INCLUDE
QUALIFIED TO USE WITH THE NET
PROVIDERS OF ANIMAL REHAB
SERVICES AND FURTHERMORE WE ASK
FOR THIS BOARD IS GRANTED AN
EXTENSION FOR JUST TWO YEARS
INSTEAD OF FOUR. BECAUSE WE
FEEL THE NECESSITATE MORE
STRINGENT OVERSIGHT BASED ON
THEIR PAST CONDUCT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. TESTIFYING I THINK
WE'VE HEARD OF. FOR MORE THAN
THREE MINUTES FROM BOTH THIS.
AND OPPOSITE NOW SO. ANY
FURTHER WITH. YOU'RE LIMITED TO
NAME. YOUR POSITION. ON THE
BILL YOU'RE AFFILIATION NEXT
PLEASE. ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS THAT NANCY
EHRLICH I AM THE REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECH I AM A
REGISTERED VETERINARY
TECHNICIAN AND THE REGULATORY
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA REGISTERED
VETERINARY TECHNICIANS
ASSOCIATION- WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL- WE HAD SOME- QUESTIONED
ABOUT IT BUT NOW YOU'RE NOT
LETTING US SPEAK SO. I WILL SAY
THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE NEXT
PLEASE. NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR KAREN
MEMBERS JENNIFER PAIRING WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA WE
REMAIN NEUTRAL ON EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE BUT I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE CONCERNS
NOTED THE ANALYSIS OF THE BILLS
CURRENTLY MISSING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE CLEAR
DIRECTION TO THE BOARD TO
EXPAND TELEMEDICINE BY
ELIMINATING THEIR REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR AN IN PERSON
VISIT TO ESTABLISH A B. C. P.
R. WE MUST IMPROVE ACCESS TO.
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA TO LIVE IN
REMOTE RURAL OR OTHER
VETERINARY GATHERED THOSE WITH
MOBILITY OR TRANSPORTATION
ISSUES AN ANIMAL TO THE WELFARE
MAYBE COMPROMISED BY TRAVEL AND
IN PERSON THAT THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
RESEARCHERS ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. OKAY
LET'S SAY A FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FINNEY REMAINS LET'S
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE SAYING NONE LET'S TURN
TO THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT AN INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
ONE FIVE THREE FIVE WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU TO THE
TEST PLAN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND ALL
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS MEASURE. SEEING NONE IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ARCH
LETTER SO MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE EXPECTED US RIVAL.
THE MOTION IS TO PRESS REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE
THE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ROSS. ROSS I MELINDA'S
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA IBEATS. ALL
RIGHT. BAYSIDE BACKER ALL RIGHT
BACKER I DON HI DON I ADMIN.
ADRIAN I HER TADO HI HER TADO
I'D JONES. JONES I. A. LEYVA HI
LLEVA ICEMEN. MAIN I NEWMAN
NEWMAN I I'D SHOW ABOUT OKAY
UNTIL BOTH IPN HI CAN I. BILL
AS THIRTEEN VOTES WILL STILL
HOLD ROLE OPEN. NEXT ITEM FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE FIVE THREE SIX BOARD
OF OCCASIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS SOME
REMEMBER LOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN CALLING THIS
IS A FINAL BILL PRESENTATION
FOR THE SUNSET BILLS ON
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX ON THE BORDER VOCATIONAL
NURSING AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS. FOR THE ONE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT I IS
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER LAYING ON
THE COUCH YOU KNOW RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU SIR WHAT
IS SHE MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND
ESPECIALLY THANK YOU MR LOW.
AND ALL GREAT STAFF OF THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU LET'S TURN TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX. THING
NOW LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT AN INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU I MISS HEARING CENTERS MY
NAME IS TOBY PRESIDED
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS ADAPTED AS A
SUPPORT DOCUMENTED POSITION ON
THIS BILL WE'RE SPEAKING THE
LANGUAGE TO INCLUDE AUTHORITY
FOR THE COURT TO IMPLEMENT A
PEACE STRUCTURE. FOR REGULATING
AND ACCREDITING SCHOOLS IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN THE FUND'S
SOLVENCY AND STOP PLAYING THE
FISCAL BURDEN OF THE BOARD'S
FUNCTIONS SOLELY ON THE BACK OF
ITS LICENSEE- IF THE COMMITTEE
CHOOSES TO ONLY EXTEND. AND THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD CONSIDER
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
THE BOARD FROM RAISING FEES ON
LATE FEES UNTIL THE COMMITTEE
ADDRESSES THE SCHOOL FEE.
ACCREDITING AND REGULATING L.
V. N. N. P. PROGRAM TAKES A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY PAID FOR BY
A HEALTHY AND HE HE LICENSE
FEES. EACH TIME THE BOARD HAS A
FUND SOLVENCY ISSUES THEY RAISE
FEES ON THE LICENSE FEES WHILE
STILL CHARGING NOTHING FOR THE
SCHOOLS THEY REGULATE AND
PROVIDE ACCREDITATION- THE
TUITION OF MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE OFTEN IN THE
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR RANGE. LICENSEES NOT
ONLY HAVE TO PAY FOR TUITION
THEY ALSO HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
SCHOOLS TO GET ACCREDITED AND
REGULATED- THIS IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE I HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR SCHOOLS TO PAY FOR THE PORT
SERVICES THAT THEY UTILIZE FOR
TEN YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN
LOOKING. IT'S TIME TO STOP
BURNING THE LICENSE FEES FOR
ALL THE RESOURCES OF THE BOARD-
FOR THAT BUT HE HE AND THE LPN
PROGRAMS USED TO GET ACCREDITED
AND REGULATED IT. FOR THESE
REASONS WE HAVE A. SUPPORT
COMMAND THE POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT. NAME
POSITION PHILLY IF. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME EXPRESSED SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX.
AND KNOW WHETHER PARTICIPANTS
ARE QUEUED UP THANK YOU LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. LET'S BEGIN WITH
OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SAYING NONE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY AGAINST HER
IN A POSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX SEEING NONE.
TURN TO THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICE MODERATOR FEUD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
PARTICIPANTS ARE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
REGARDING THIS MEASURE. SENATOR
PAN FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DODD
FRANK THANK YOU FOR THIS CHAIR
AND- I KNOW THAT- A CHAIR LOWS-
VERY MUCH AWARE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD IN THE
NUMEROUS BOARDS ABOUT RAISING
FEES FOR LICENSEES AND- AND
EXACTLY WHERE THAT MONEY GOES
TO. DID YOU JUST BRIEFLY
PERHAPS ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
REGARDING FEES FOR THEIR- FOR
THE LICENSEES WHICH THAT ARE
USED TO ACTUALLY PAY FOR. THESE
SCHOOLS ACCREDITATION. ISSUES
WHILE THEY'RE NOT SELL THEIR
CAGES ADDRESS THAT ISSUE YEAH
THEY DO VERY MUCH TALK TO PAM-
THROUGH THE CHAIR I KNOW THAT
TO THE CHAIR AND I HAVE BEEN
HAVING A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS ON THE BURDEN ON
THAT OF THE- LICENSEES IN THAT
OF SCHOOLS. AS YOU WELL KNOW
WHEN PART OF THE CONVERSATIONS
IN THE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
THERE'S BEEN DIALOGUE ABOUT
INCREASING FEES FOR THE SCHOOLS
TO LESSEN THE BURDENS OF THAT
OF LICENSEES AS WELL AS PERHAPS
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT- TO HELP
ENSURE THAT WE CAN MITIGATE THE
TYPE OF IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE
SO I KNOW THAT THESE ARE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS THAT. THE
CHAIRMAN RALPH AND I ARE BOTH
HAVING. AS WELL AS AT THE STAFF
LEVEL. THANK YOU IF I CAN DO
ADD ON TO THAT OF ONE OF THE
ISSUE THAT WE- THE CHAIR AND I.
WITH ALL OF YOU HERE IN IN THE
ASSEMBLY HOPE TO PURSUE AT THE
BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR IS TO
EXPLORE THIS APPROVAL PROCESS
BOTH FOR THIS PARTICULAR GROUP
OF PORTS AND OTHERS AS TO
WHETHER THE APPROVAL PROCESS IS
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE AND
WHETHER IT'S DONE WHETHER IT'S
DUPLICATIVE EFFORT DUPLICATIVE
OF EFFORTS BY OTHER.
ORGANIZATIONS TO APPROVE IN A
CREDIT AND THEN OF COURSE TAKE
A LOOK AT THE FEES THAT MAY BE
ASSESSED BECAUSE IN MANY CASES
WHEN W ASSESS FEES ON SCHOOLS
SCHOOLS PASSED A FEAT THESE ARE
THE STUDENTS AND THE TUITION IS
INCREASED AND SO. IT'S A IT'S A
RATHER A DETAILED PROCESS BUT
WE NEED TO DO IT QUICKLY AND WE
JOINTLY PLANNED TO DO IT WITH
ALL OF YOU- NEXT YEAR DURING
THE SUNSET EXTENSION. SENATOR
MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR DONE. THE REMEMBER
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE GOVERNMENT RESEARCHER AT
AND COLLEAGUES AS WE CLOSE ON
THE FINAL BILL PRESENTATION
TODAY- FOR THE SINS OF HUMANS
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INDULGENCE AND PARTICIPATION IN
THE SIXTEEN. OR SO BOARDS AND
BUREAUS AND COUNCILS THAT WE'VE
HAD INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS AND
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM TWELVE MAYBE
FIFTEEN THIRTY SIXTY PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROTH. ROTH I'M
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
IBEATS. BECKER BACKER EYED
DAUGHTER. DONNA HI AIKMAN
EGGMAN I. HER TADO HER TADO I'D
JONES JONES I. LEIVA LEVI MEN.
MAN I KNEW MAN THE MAN I I'D
SHOW A BOGUS. A TERRIBLE GUY
HAN HAN I. BILL HAS TWELVE
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROPE AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR LOCAL. I
DON'T REMEMBER OKAY YEAH I
THINK IS.
BUT SIR TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHAT WE'RE
WAITING FOR A FINAL AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KNOWS ARE IN. WE
NEED A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
MAY I HAVE ONE. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. IN THE FIRST. THE
KING THANK OUR UNDER FILE ITEM
Q. EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY AND FILE
ITEM FIVE A. B. ELEVEN OH TWO
RALPH HI RALPH HI MELINDA'S.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BE.
BACKER BECKER I DAUGHTER DOT I
EXAMINE HEY MAN I HEARD TOMATO.
HER TADO I'D JOHNS JONES I.
LEIVA LEAVE A ICEMEN MAN I KNEW
MAN. THE MAN I I'D SHOW ABODE
BUT SHOW A BUG EYED HAN. CAN I.
TWELVE VOTES WILL HOLD THAT
OPEN. I SEE. SEMI MEMBERS ARE
IN HERE YOU HAVE TWO MEASURES
SIR WE WILL START WITH FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINE TWO CLINICAL
LABORATORIES. THANK YOU MEANT
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- TODAY
I'M BRINGING YOU A- USUALLY
IT'S FACETIOUS TO SAY BUT
RELATIVELY SIMPLE BILL WITH NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS I'VE WORKED ON
LEGISLATION EIGHTY SIX THIRTEEN
AND A. B. TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE THAT WOULD MODERNIZE AND
MAKE MORE EFFICIENT THE
COLLECTION OF SOURCE PLASMA
PROTEIN. IN CALIFORNIA BY
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ALLOWED TO ADMINISTER A TOTAL
PROTEIN TEST AT A PLASMA
DONATION CENTER MOST PACIFIC WE
HAVE WORKED ON A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ALLOW A TOTAL
PROTEIN TEST. USING A DEVICE
CALLED A DIGITAL REFRACTOMETER
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY TRAINED
STAFF PERSON IN A PLASMA
DONATION CENTER. AB THREE
NINETY TWO SIMPLY REQUIRES CDPH
TO DETERMINE THAT A PERSON
USING THIS DEVICE DO SO IN
ACCORDANCE WITH STANDARDIZED
PROCEDURES APPROVED BY RATHER
THAN APPROVED AND DEVELOPED BY
THE LICENSE PLASMA CENTERS
SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN OR
CLINICAL LABORATORY DIRECTOR.
MY OFFICE THE SPONSOR AND CD
PETER CURRENTLY WORKING ON A
WAY TO ASSESS THE COMPETENCY OF
THE PILOT OPERATORS THAT MEETS
THE DEPARTMENT'S STANDARDS
HOWEVER I WILL NOTE THAT
CURRENT STATUTE IS SILENT ON
THE NEED FOR AN ASSESSMENT BY
CDPH- THE STATUTE DOES REQUIRE
THE ASSESSMENT OF THE PILOT
OPERATORS BY THE C. L. I. A.
WHICH IS THE CLINICAL
LABORATORY IMPROVEMENT.
AMENDMENTS OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT LAB SUPERVISOR AT THE
PLASMA DONATION CENTER
CURRENTLY THIS IS DONE EVERY
SIX MONTHS DUE TO THE INCREASED
WORKLOAD ON CD PH BECAUSE OF
KOBE NINETEEN THE DATA REVIEW
PROCESS HAS BEEN SEVERELY
DELAYED. NEVER THE LESS I HAVE
A COMMITMENT FROM THE CURRENT
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR DR ERIC ON.
THAT THEY WILL COMPLETE THEIR
REVIEW OF THE DATA FROM THE
PILOT PROJECT SOON ONCE THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK SIGNS A
BILL THAT RECENTLY PASSED THEIR
LEGISLATURE CALIFORNIA WILL BE
THE ONLY STATE THAT REQUIRES A
LICENSED INDIVIDUAL TO PERFORM
THE TOTAL PROTEIN TEST AT A
PLASMA DONATION CENTER. THEY
SHOULDN'T BE THE CASE PLASMA
DONATIONS ARE NECESSARY FOR THE
CREATION OF PLASMA PROTEIN
THERAPIES THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
MANY INDIVIDUALS WITH RARE
CHRONIC CAN DO. THIS IS WHY
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY SUCH
A WIDE COALITION OF ADVOCATES.
TO TESTIFY AND JOIN JOINED BY
MISTER BILL SPEAR SENIOR
DIRECTOR ADVOCACY AND
REGULATORY POLICY FOR THAT.
PLASMA PROTEIN THERAPEUTICS
ASSOCIATION AND- JIMMY SEXTON
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY FOR
THE IMMUNE DEFICIENCY
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU SIR
WITNESSES YOU MAY PROCEED. HI
THIS IS BILL SPEAR WITH PTA-
PICKETED GRATEFUL FOR THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT OF A PILOT
PROJECT IN PRIOR LEGISLATIVE
SESSIOS THEN WE'D APPRECIATE
YOUR FAVORABLE LOOK TODAY I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
AND THANK YOU FOR TALKING YOU
TESTIFIED TO HEARING MY NAME IS
JEANNIE BACK THEN AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
IMMUNE DEFICIENCY FOUNDATION.
WE REPRESENT AN ESTIMATED
THIRTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
DIAGNOSED WITH PRIMARY
IMMUNODEFICIENCY AND MANY MORE
THAT ARE UNDERTAKING AND WE
REQUEST YOUR FAVORABLE THOSE
TODAY TO HELP AND CAN'T SUPPLY
OF LIFE BEING THERAPIES. FOR
PATIENTS WITH SERIOUS MEDICAL
CONDITIONS INCLUDING THOSE WITH
PRIMARY. IMMUNODEFICIENCY THANK
YOU. HEY YOU. LET'S TURN TO ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE WITNESSES
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINE
TWO. SAYINGNONE TURNING TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINE TWO WE
WILL PROCEED. D. LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE WILL GO FIRST TO
LINE ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CATHERINE PETTIBONE
BALLISTIC GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
UP TO HALF OF IT A
PHARMACEUTICAL STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN JUST A MOMENT
WE HAVE TWO LINES PENDING. FOR
THE FIRST ONLINE. ONE TWENTY
TWO. ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
TELEPHONE LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS UNDER YOUR PARENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFELINE STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CONNIE GOT CAUGHT ON
BEHALF OF CRIPPLED IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NOT FOR THE LINE CAN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST BEGINNING WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE. SAYING NONE
LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. HE WOULD ONCE AGAIN
PROMPTED THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY TWO. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THOSE WITNESSES. THANK YOU
WE LIKE THE STATE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
COLONEL TELEPHONE LINES N THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. REGARDING
THIS MEASURE. SEEING NONE
SIRLEAF HAS MOVED MOVED THE
BILL SIMPLY MEMBERS- AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IPHONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOLLOW ADAM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE NINETY TWO DO YOU PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR ROTH IRA. ROTH
IRA MELINDA'S ARCHULETA- TO LET
I BEAT. BACKER ALL RIGHT BACKER
I. DODD I THOUGHT I A MAN BY I
MEAN I HER TADO HI HER TADO I'D
JONES. JONES I. LEIVA HI LEAVE
A ICEMEN. MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN
I'D SHOW A BOGUS I'M A SHOW
ABOUT IPN BY HAND I. MEASURES
FOR VOTES WILL HOLD ROLE OPEN.
NEXT ITEM IN OUR FINAL ITEM
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWO SEVEN EIGHT SO MY
MEMORIES ARE IN YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READING. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND WELL. IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION AND EVEN MORE
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL- FIRST AND
FOREMOST BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT
TO THANK YOU MR CHAIR- FOR YOUR
GUIDANCE. LIKE TO ALSO THANK
THE WONDERFUL WORK OF YOUR
STAFF AND TEAM- THEY WERE
AMAZING AND HELPING WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT I'VE WORKED ON
LAST WEEK- AND THE RAPID
TURNAROUND THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR WORK-
COLLEAGUES I I'VE SPOKEN TO YOU
TO MANY OF YOU ARE ALL OF YOU.
AT THIS POINT OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST- SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
AND I'M SORRY SEVEN DAYS TO TEN
DAYS. AND AS A RESULT OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS I'VE AMENDED MY
BILL TO REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT A PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON
PROVIDE A WRITTEN DISCLOSURE OF
THE NAMES OF ALL DRUG AND
DEVICE COMPANIES. HE OR SHE HAS
RECEIVED PAYMENT OR TRANSFER OF
VALUE FROM AS REPORTED ON THE
OPEN RECORDS DATABASE. SO WHAT
DOES THIS BILL DO. SIMPLY PUT A
B. TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
REQUIRES PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS TO DO ONE THING AND
ONE THING ALONE. TO NOTIFY
PATIENTS OF THE EXISTENCE OF
THE OPEN PAYMENTS DATABASE. AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT REQUIRES
THIS TO BE DONE THREE DIFFERENT
WAYS ONE TO PROVIDE A WRITTEN
NOTICE THAT THE PATIENTMUST
SIGN. HOPEFULLY THE SIGNATURE
WILL GET MORE PEOPLE TO READ
THE FORM. THIS CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE WAITING
ROOM AND IS NOT REQUIRED TO BE
DONE BY THE PHYSICIAN OR
SURGEON DURING VISIT. TO POSTED
IN A LOCATION IN AN AREA THAT
IS LIKELY TO BE SEEN BY ALL
PERSONS WHO ENTERED THE OFFICE.
THREE POST THE OPEN PAYMENTS
DATABASE NOTICE ON THE INTERNET
WEBSITE USED TO PUT THE
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS
PRACTICE. WHY THREE DIFFERENT
WAYS OF NOTIFICATION THE SAME
REASON PEPSI AND COKE USE TV
RADIO PRINT AND THE INTERNET
SIMPLY BECAUSE- PEOPLE PROCESS
INFORMATION DIFFERENTLY. SOME
MAY SEE THE POST A NOTICE IN
THE LOBBY OTHERS MAY NOT. SOME
MAY SEE IT ONLINE OTHERS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
AND THERE'S ALSO DIFFERENCES IN
DEMOGRAPHICS AND HOW EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP APPROACHES
INFORMATION. WHAT IS THE OPEN
PAYMENTS DATABASE AND WHY ALL
THE FUSS. THE DATABASE IS AN
EASY TO USE FEDERAL WEBSITE
WHICH LISTS FINANCIAL EXCHANGES
BETWEEN DRUG AND DEVICE
MANUFACTURERS AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS GOING BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS TYPE IN YOUR DOCTOR'S
NAME AND YOU CAN SEE IF THEY'VE
RECEIVED COMPENSATION FOR
RESEARCH INDUSTRY SPONSORED
EDUCATION. OR FREE LUNCH. THE
PROBLEM I'M TRYING TO SOLVE IS
THAT NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT IT. THE
SOLUTION IS TO NOTIFY PATIENTS
OF THE DATABASE AND WE NEED TO
DO THAT REPETITIVELY SO IT
STICKS. WHILE ACCEPTING THESE
PAYMENTS DO NOT NECESSARILY
TRANSLATE INTO A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST THE DATABASE PROVIDES
THE PATIENT WITH INFORMATION
THAT MAY HELP THEM MAKE BETTER
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH CARE. IN THE CASE OF MY
CONSTITUENT WINDY CONNECT WHO
UNDERWENT BREAST RECONSTRUCTION
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
FOLLOWING A DOUBLE MASTECTOMY
SHE OPTED FOR SURGERIES AFTER
TESTING REVEALED THAT SHE- HAD
THE BRCA GENE WHICH MADE HER
SUSCEPTIBLE TO BREAST CANCER.
NOW MY CONSTITUENT IS LIVING
WITH CHRONIC PAIN AFTER
EXPERIENCING SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS FOLLOWING HER
SURGERY. SHE LEARNED THAT HER
PHYSICIAN HAD RECEIVED MORE
HAN FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD FROM THE
MANUFACTURER OF THE DEVICE USED
IN HER SURGERY. THIS
INFORMATION WAS AVAILABLE ON
THE FEDERAL DATABASE BUT SHE
DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT ITS EXISTENCE.
SHE LEARNED SHE ALSO LEARNED
THAT THE DEVICE ITSELF WAS
EXPERIMENTAL FOR BREAST
RECONSTRUCTION AND HAD NOT BEEN
APPROVED BY THE FDA. BY THE WAY
COLLEAGUES. MY CONSTITUENTS
HUSBAND IS A DOCTOR HE WAS NOT
AWARE OF THIS WEBSITE. AND
WINDY KNOWN ABOUT THIS SHE MAY
HAVE ASKED MORE QUESTIONS AND
MOST LIKELY WOULD HAVE REACHED
OUT. FOR A SECOND OPINION.
FINANCIAL RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
PHYSICIANS AND MEDICAL PRODUCT
MANUFACTURERS ARE COMMON. AND
THEY'RE CERTAINLY NOT ALL BAD
HOWEVER THEYCAN ALSO CREATE
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND IN
SOME CASES CAN BE LEARNED A LOT
BLUR THE LINES BETWEEN
PROMOTIONAL ACTIVITIES AND THE
CONDUCT OF MEDICAL RESEARCH
TRAINING AND PRACTICE. A TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ANALYSIS BY
PROPUBLICA FOUND THAT ON
AVERAGE DOCTORS WHO RECEIVED
PAYMENTS PRESCRIBED 50% MORE OF
THAT DRUG THE DOCTORS WHO DID
NOT NOW I CAN ALSO DEBATE THAT
POINT AND I CAN TELL YOU. THAT
MAYBE FOR MOST DOCTORS THAT
PRODUCT IS THE BEST PRODUCT ON
THE MARKET. AND THAT IT HAPPENS
TO COINCIDE ALSO WITH A GREATER
AMOUNT OF MARKETING BUT NOT THE
OTHER WAY AROUND SO I CAN SEE
THAT AS WELL. A SEPARATE STUDY
CONCLUDED THAT THE RECEIPT OF
INDUSTRY SPONSORED MEALS WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASED
RATE OF PRESCRIBING THE
PROMOTED BRAND NAME MEDICATION
RELATIVE TO ALTERNATIVES WITHIN
THE DRUG CLASS. RECENT
OPPOSITION STATES THERE IS NO
NEED FOR THIS BILL. LET THE
FEDERAL OPEN PAYMENTS WEBSITE
ALREADY ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF
DISCLOSURE I AGREE. I AGREE
WITH THE OPPOSITION. THERE IS A
DISCLOSURE IN PLACE HOWEVER.
WHAT THEY FAIL TO MENTION IS
THAT VERY FEW PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT
THIS TOOL THAT IT EVEN EXISTS
AGAIN ALL TWELVE SEVENTY DOES.
IT AT THE LOCAL STATE LEVEL
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THIS
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING
DOCTORS TO SIMPLY DISCLOSE
WHERE TO ACCESS THE FEDERAL
DATABASE. BY DOING THIS WE
ENSURE THAT THIS NECESSARY
INFORMATION GETS TO ITS
INTENDED AUDIENCE THE PATIENT.
ALLOWS THE PATIENT ALLOWS
PHYSICIANS TO PROVIDE CONTEXT
TO THE RECOMMENDATION
RECOMMENDED CARE. DRUG AND
DEVICE MANUFACTURERS ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE
THESE PAYMENTS AND THIS GREAT
WEBSITE MAKES IT SO EASY FOR
THE PUBLIC TO SEE THE DATA. BUT
THE ONUS REMAINS ON US THE
CONSUMER TO KNOW THIS
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE AND TO
SEE GET OUT MY BILL BILL IS
DESIGNED TO NOT BE PUNITIVE
RATHER IT IS WRITTEN TO EMPOWER
PATIENTS TO MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES ABOUT THEIR HEALTH
CARE. I HOPE IT WILL CREATE A
STRONGER PATIENT DOCTOR
RELATIONSHIP THROUGH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY I'M JOINED BY MY
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THE CONNECT
WHO IS HAD TO HAVE SIX
SURGERIES AFTER THE
RECONSTRUCTIVE SURGERY AND
STILL LIVES WITH PAIN. AND ALSO
BY DR CHARLES ROSEN PRESIDENT
OF THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
MEDICAL ETHICS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE WILL MOVE ON
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL. LET ME- REMIND THOSE WHO
WERE GOING TO BE TESTIFYING
BOTH AS LEADS AND SUPPORT AND
LEAVES AN OPPOSITION- I
RECOGNIZE THIS IS A SENSITIVE
TOPIC ON BOTH SIDES SO I BUT I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU TRY TO.
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO THE
THREE MINUTES THAT ARE
CONTAINED IN OUR- COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE RULES SO LET'S
PROCEED WITH- DOCTOR ROSEN. AND
MS CONNECT WITNESSES YOU MAY
PROCEED. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
PERFECTLY. OKAY HI MY NAME IS
WENDY CONNECT MY STORY IS ONE
OF CHRONIC PAIN DEFORMITY AND
NUMEROUS CORRECTIVE SURGERY HI
MY DEVICE THAT EXPLODED INSIDE
ME THE DEVICE MY SURGEON HAD
BEEN PAID ALMOST HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS TWO RESEARCH AND
PROMOTE. BUT HE NEVER TOLD US
ABOUT THE MONEY MY STORY COULD
BE YOUR STORY I AM AN INFORMED
CONSUMER MY HUSBAND IS A
PHYSICIAN BUT EVEN THOUGH WE
HAD NO IDEA ABOUT THE OPEN
PAYMENTS WEBSITE WE DO NOT HAVE
ALL THE INFORMATION AND WE HAD
NO JUST REASON TO DISTRACT MY
THIRTEEN. KNOWING ABOUT OPEN
PAYMENT WOULD HAVE SAVED ME.
YEARS OF PAIN AND DEFORMITY. I
HAVE DONE EVERY I WOULD ASK THE
RIGHT. AND I WOULD HAVE WANTED
TO KNOW MORE IN IN A MILLION
YEARS I NEVER WOULD HAVE
CONSENTED. TO HAVING THAT
DEVICE IMPLANTED INSIDE ME.
I'VE BEEN THINKING TOO MANY
DOCTORS THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
MOST ETHICAL DOCTORS DISCLOSED
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
THESE DOCTORS KNOW THAT
PATIENTS TRUSTED DOCTOR MORE IT
JUST CLOSES. ESPECIALLY THOSE
STOCKS INVOLVED IN INNOVATIONS.
AND RESEARCH PATIENT BLOOD.
AGENTS NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THE
OPEN PAYMENTS. INTENDED REACH
TO INFORM PATIENTS WOULD NEVER
ACHIEVED THAT DOCTORS ARE NOT
AFRAID OF TRANSPARENCY THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE. EIGHT ONE
TWO SEVEN EIGHT IS ABOUT
PROTECTING PATIENTS LIKE ME YOU
AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS I AM
HELPING THEM TO HAVE ALL THE
ESSENTIAL INFORMATION THEY NEED
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH. IF YOU AND
I HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT AB ONE
TWO SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU MA'AM
DR ROSEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
PERFECTLY. MY NAME IS ROSE ROSE
INCREDIBLE PROFESSOR OF
ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY AT THE UCLA
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND A
PRACTICING PHYSICIAN FOR THIRTY
YEARS. AS WELL AS PRESIDENT OF
THE ASSOCIATION FOR MEDICAL
ETHICS I WORK WITH SENATORS
GRASSLEY AND CALLED SPONSORING
THE PHYSICIAN PAYMENT SUNSHINE
ACT FOR WHICH I TESTIFIED
BEFORE CONGRESS DURING
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S FIRST TERM.
THE ACT THAT REQUIRES ALL
MEDICAL COMPANIES REPORT TO THE
CENTER FOR MEDICARE THE DOCTORS
JIM THEY'RE PAYING MONEY OR THE
LIKE. AND HOW MUCH. PART OF
LEGALLY. IN ORGANS ADULT
PATIENTS HAVE A TO KNOW.
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST AND THEIR
MEDICAL TREATMENT. INDUSTRY
VIGOROUSLY RESISTED THE SMART
ANIMAL RESEARCH AND MEDICAL
PRACTICE WITH YOUR INDEPENDENT
WITHOUT FINANCIAL FINANCIAL BY.
WHEN IT INVOLVES PATIENTS
BODIES AND THEIR LIVES AND HOW
THEY DARN WELL HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW THIS IS ANGELA THIS. TO BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR EIGHTY TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT ONLY HAVE
PATIENTS RECEIVE A PIECE OF
PAPER THAT GIVE THEM THE
ADDRESS OF THE DATABASE AND
POSTED ON THE WALL ALL TE
OTHER NOTICES AND ON THE
DOCTOR'S WEBSITE. THAT IS ALL
NOTHING MORE I AM A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN AND THIS WOULD NOT
BURDENSOME. THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NO REQUIREMENT FOR THE POSITION
TO VERBALLY NORM BRADY DISCLOSE
ANY COMPANIES OR REIMBURSEMENT.
NAMELY NOTHING INTERFERES WITH
THE BUSINESS. VOTING FOR THIS
BILL IS A VOTE FOR TRANSPARENCY
AND HAITIAN HERE. MAKE NO
MISTAKE THE VOTE AGAINST IT IN
BOTH CHRISTY CHRISTY AND HER
INDUSTRY PROFIT OVER PATIENT
CARE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
NOW LET'S TURN TO ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. I SEE
NONE LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A B. ONE TWO
SEVEN EIGHT. SIGNAL LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWO SEVEN
EIGHT WE WILL BEGIN. TO EXPRESS
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILLING
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
THE NUMBER ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE PHOTO LINE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING REBECCA MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRE OF PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW ONE OF THE BILL'S
CO SPONSORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE. FIFTY TWO. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AARON BROWN
WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THE FORTY FORTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT WILL
HELP CONSUMERS AS THEY MAKE
INFORMED CHOICES AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR
PHYSICIAN REGARDING THEIR
MEDICAL CARE AND TREATMENT IN
THE US FOR AN ADULT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. IF THERE
ARE ANYOTHER ADDITIONAL LINES
OF LIKE THE STATE SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL PRESS ONE AND ZERO.
WHAT BETTER KNOW FOR ALLIANCE
SECURITIES TIME STRUCTURE THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR LET'S FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION I BELIEVE EMILY
HUGHES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION INTO
MADDEN. ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
POSITION GROUPS ARE BOTH HERE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION FIRST
MISUSE. GOOD AFTERNOON NOW
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
EMILY HUGHES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
IN OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT. ALTHOUGH
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S ATTEMPT AT IMPROVING
THIS BILL IT CONTINUES TO
CREATE AN ENORMOUS
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR ALL
POSITIONS DESPITE WHETHER THEY
THEMSELVES EVEN EXIST ON THE
OPEN PAYMENTS DATABASE. CMA IS
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE OPEN PAYMENTS
WEBSITE AND DATABASE AND
THEY'RE IN. AS SUCH WE SUPPORT
A FULLY INFORMED HE IS A
PATIENT POPULATION AS SUCH WE
FELT IT WOULD BE MORE THAN
SUFFICIENT TO POST A VISUAL
NOTIFICATION CONSPICUOUSLY IN
EVERY OFFICE LOBBY IN ADDITION
TO REQUIRING EVERY PATIENT SIGN
A WRITTEN DISCLOSURE AT INITIAL
PATIENT INTAKE. THIS COMPROMISE
EFFICIENTLY INFORMS THE PATIENT
IS THE AUTHOR'S INTENT WITHOUT
PLACING AN ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
PHYSICIANS. ANNUAL DISCLOSURE
WHICH THIS BILL REQUIRES
SPENDING OUT THERE HAS
CONVENIENTLY FAILED TO MENTION
WOULD INEVITABLY CREATE. EMAILS
BEEN WILLING TO MAKE THIS
COMPROMISE SINCE EARLY
CONVERSATION SHORTLY AFTER THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL AND WE
HAVE NOT WAVERED. UNFORTUNATELY
AS WRITTEN WE MUST REMAIN IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU MR MADDEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS TEN MADDEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF PLASTIC
SURGEONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR FOR THEIR TIME AND THEN
INSTRUCT US OR CONCERNS WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO EIGHTY TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT OUR PHYSICIANS
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF TRANSPARENCY.
IN FOR PATIENTS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO INFORMATION AS PROVIDED IN
THE OPEN PAYMENTS DATABASE WE
ARE CONCERNED OVER THE
REQUIREMENT TO CONTINUALLY
PROVIDE DISCLOSURES TO PATIENTS
THAT WILL LEAD THEM TO
AUTOMATICALLY FEEL THERE IS A
CONFLICT WITH PHYSICIANS
ATTENDING INDUSTRY EDUCATIONAL
EVENTS AND SEMINARS THESE
EDUCATIONAL SEMINARS HELD
POSITIONS BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT MEDICATIONS ARE AVAILABLE
TO PROVIDE THE BEST CARE FOR
THEIR PATIENTS. IF PATIENTS
AUTOMATICALLY BELIEVE THERE IS
A CONFLICT FOR PHYSICIANS TO GO
TO THE SEMINARS PATIENTS WILL
BECOME HESITANT TO EITHER FILL
THE PESCRIPTIONS OR HERE TO
THE PRESCRIBED MEDICATIONS FOR
THESE REASONS REMAIN OPPOSED AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SIR ARE THERE ANY OF WHAT THIS
IS IN THE GALLERY WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SAYING
NONE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT I SEE NONE
LET'S GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT. ASSAYED%
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE WE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER NINETY FIVE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M WAY
OVER TOP ON BEHALF OF BY
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WE HAD IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS BILL
FROM BOTH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR THAT
HE OUTLINED AT THE BEGINNING.
WE WILL REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
LINE. ONE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ANDRE
GOOD TERRACE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES DIDN'T
FEEL AS ALTER MOOD OPPOSITION
GIVEN THE AUTHOR AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
WHERE LINE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND I
THINK I CAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS MAINTAINING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. ONE TWENTY SIX IT ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGIST
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN ONE ONE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND IT'S CEAR THIS
NOT REPRESENTING THE OCCUPIED
THE POSITIONS IN CERTAIN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY LET'S
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SENATOR PAN FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
BECKER SENATOR MAN. THANK YOU
TEAR OFF AND- I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR OUR
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE BILL
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HE TOOK- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
DON'T OPPOSE THE IDEA OF
NOTIFICATION I KNOW YOU TALKED
ABOUT THREE DIFFERENT PATHS-
FOR- INFORMING PEOPLE ABOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE DATABASE I DO
HAVE TO SAY I WAS AWARE OF THE
EXISTENCE OF THE DATABASE- IN
MY PRACTICE BUT- I GUESS THE
QUESTION THE CONCERN I HAVE
THOUGH IS THAT- AND- WOULD BE
IS- SERVED IN. RECORDKEEPING
BURDEN SO FOR THE PRACTICE SO-
SO THE ISSUE WOULD BE IS THAT
IT WHAT KIND OF DOCUMENTATION
DOES THE PRACTICE ITSELF WOULD
HAVE TO MAINTAIN TO SHOW THAT
IT DID THESE THINGS SO YOUNG WE
HAVE A FIXED THING ON THE WALL
WE HAVE THE WEBSITE. AND THEN
THE- SIGNED STATEMENTS- THAT
YOU'RE ASKING THE PASTEL BOTH
INITIALLY AND ANNUALLY. BUT IS
THE PRACTICE GOING TO HAVE TO
THEN BE REQUIRED TO SIMPLY KEEP
A FILING CABINET FULL OF. YOU
KNOW COPIES OF THESE NOW THE
BASICALLY STATEMENT- WITH
SIGNATURES- SO WITH THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF SOMEONE ELSE COMES BY
TO SHOW THAT THEY ACTUALLY GAVE
IT IN THE LAST YEAR. OR WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO- BE WILLING TO
TAKE SOME LANGUAGE TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU. HAVE TO GIVE THE
STATEMENT- BUT- YOU DON'T NEED
TO KEEP A- A- BASICALLY COPY OF
EACH ONE FOR EVERY SINGLE
PATIENT SO THAT- THAT YOU CAN
BASICALLY SHOW THAT THIS IS
WHAT WE NORMALLY DO IN OUR
OFFICE. THAT WOULD BE GOOD
ENOUGH SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE. A FILING CABINETS FULL OF
BASICALLY PIECES OF PAPER OR
REPROGRAM EHRS. AS EVIDENCE OF-
THE FILLING THAT PARTICULAR
REQUIREMENTS SO AGAIN REDUCING
THE COSTS THE OVERHEAD OF
BURDEN OF. MAINTENANCE AND
STILL ACHIEVING ESSENTIALLY THE
SAME AIMS THAT YOU'RE CHEATING
WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE GET
NOTICED AND THERE WILL BE
DIFFERENT WAYS PEOPLE WOULD GET
THE NOTIFICATION. OF THE
EXISTENCE OF THE DATABASE.
REMEMBER HAPPY TO RESPOND I
RESEARCH I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT ME TO RESPOND TO
EVERYTHING AS WE GO OR ALL AT
ONCE HAPPY TO RESPOND BECAUSE I
SUSPECT A LOT OF THE ARGUMENTS
ARE GOING TO BE SIMILAR
SIMILARLY ORIENTED BUT- I'M
HAPPY TO GO ONE BY ONE. WELL I.
WILL LEAVE IT UP TO YOU EXCEPT
THE- SENATOR PAN MAY HAVE ASK
QUESTIONS THAT OTHERS MAY ASK
IN YOUR RESPONSE TO HIM MAY
ADDRESS OTHERS CONCERNED HAPPY
TO HAPPY TO SO. AT JUST TO BE
CLEAR ON THE DOCUMENTATION SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. JUST THE
SHEER NUMBER AND VOLUME OF
PAPERS. RIGHT BEING COLLECTED
OKAY- YEP HEALTH CARE AND DATA
COLLECTION HAS COME A LONG WAY
WE DO HAVE A COLLECTION OF DATA
YOU DATABASE WE DO HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW. FOR SUCH
REDUNDANT MEASURES TO BE DONE
RELATIVELY QUICKLY AND- ALSO
FOR A GOOD RECORD KEEPING SO
THAT IT DOESN'T CREATED
MINISTER OF BURDENS I'M VERY
SENSITIVE ESPECIALLY TO MEDICAL
CLINICS AND OFFICES IN RURAL
AREAS THAT MAY NOT HAVE. THE
PHYSICIANS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS LET ALONE ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANTS THAT
WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
THIS I DID PUT SOME THOUGHT
INTO THIS ALONG WITH WITH THE
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL TO MAKE
SURE WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE IT
EASY- IF YOU KNOW. I THINK AS
THESE THE BILL OFFERS A BY THE
WAY THERE'S ALSO JUST YOU YOU
DID MENTION ANNUAL SO I WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR CMA SAID
THAT I FAILED TO LET THIS BODY
NO I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER FAIL
TO LET ANYONE KNOW ANYTHING SO
I WANT TO CORRECT THAT WORDING-
THIS BILL. ASKS FOUR EIGHT
ANNUAL- UPDATING OF THE
INFORMATION BECAUSE DOCTOR PEN
THE GOAL IS REPETITION IF WE
KEEP ON REPEATING SOMETHING
SEVERAL TIMES A STUDY SUGGESTS
YOU REPEAT SOMETHING SEVEN
TIMES IT'LL STICK WITH SOMEONE
RIGHT THE IDEA IS TO REPEAT
THIS SO THAT PEOPLE SEE IT AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A YOUNGER
DEMOGRAPHIC THAT DOESN'T GO TO
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE BUT FOR
MAYBE ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS TEN
YEARS. THEY'RE NOT THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE IS NOT SUPPOSED TO THEN
GO OUT OF THEIR WAY TO MAIL THE
DOCUMENT TO THAT PERSON'S HOME
REQUIRING THEM TO SEND IT BACK
TO THEM THIS IS VERY DIFFERENT
THIS JUST SAYS THE NEXT TIME
YOU HAPPEN TO GO TO THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE YOU CAN FILL
OUT THAT SIGNED THIS DOCUMENT
WE MADE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT THE DOCTORS OFFICES NOT
BURDENED SO IT'S I JUST WANT TO
CORRECT THAT. AND YOU WILL
COMMENT. LET ME JUST SAY THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT WHAT I'M
CONCERNED IS THAT THE WET
LEASED THE WAY IT'S PHRASED
RIGHT NOW. TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT
RIGHT. SO YOU KNOW I I'M
ACTUALLY IN SOME WAYS I'M FINE
YOU KNOW WHAT. GO AHEAD GIVE IT
OUT. THE QUESTION IS THAT. THE
WAY IT'S PHRASED RIGHT NOW
THAT- WHEN SOMEONE SAYS OH DID
YOU COMPLY WITH THE LAW. SHOW
ME EVIDENCE THAT YOU HAVE.
EVERY PATIENT WHO ISSEEN ASA
SIGN DOCUMENTS IN YOUR FILES
AND I WOULD POINT OUT
PARTICULARLY RULE PRACTICES-
EITHER THE GUY DOING PAPER
WHICH TASTED HAVE TO KEEP THE
CAR YOU KNOW SOME. IN A FILING
CABINET AND THEN JUST THAT JUST
BUILDS UP- AND DISABILITY DOES
LOTS OF PAPER OR- ANY OTHER EHR
SYSTEM BUT THEN THE PROBLEM IS
IT'S NOT. A PROGRAM TO DO THIS
SO NOW THEY THEN GO BACK TO
PAPER ORDERED TO HIRE SOMEONE
TO REPROGRAM THE EHR WHICH IS
BY THE WAY EXPENSIVE TO SELL
THE BEST TIME TO BUY IT OFF THE
SHELF. SO I THINK. AS I SAID
IT'S- I'M NOT DISAGREEING WITH
YOU IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL
PROCESS OF NOTIFICATION I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY IN TERMS OF THE
OBLIGATION TO PRACTICE. FOR
FORSMAN PURPOSES RIGHT SO JUST
TO FEEL THAT THEY COMPLIED WITH
THE LAW. THAT WE NOT COMPEL THE
PRACTICE TO ACTUALLY HAVE TO
KEEP A COPY. AT A RECORD THAT
THEY GAVE THIS DOCUMENT FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL PATIENT AND THE
DATE THEY GAVE IT YOU KNOW
WHAT. THAT SHOW THAT YOU THAT.
USE THAT IN YOUR NORMAL
PRACTICES YOU HAVE IT ON THE
WALL IT'S ON YOUR WEBSITE AND
THAT. YOU KNOW THE YOUR CLERK
OR SOMETHING ATTEST TO THE FACT
THAT YOU DO PROVIDE THIS NOTICE
ON A REGULAR BASIS TO THE
PATIENTS AS THEY COME IN. AND
THAT BE SUFFICIENT TO SAY THAT
YOU COMPLY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR. BILL WHICH IF IT
BECOMES A LAW THE LAW OF THE
SIMPLIFIED TO BASICALLY
SIMPLIFY. THE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT ARE DEMANDED ON THE
PRACTICE- IS A TERMS OF- THAT'D
BE UNFORTUNATE OF THIS LITTLE.
FUTURE LAW ON THE PRESS AFTER
SO UNTRUE TO. BE SURE WE KNOW
ADDED THIS BURDEN.
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON THE
PRESS FLOOR STILL ESSENTIALLY
DOING THE SAME THING THAT
YOU'RE SEEKING. AND IF I COULD
I'D TELL JUST WRAP IT UP BY
VERY QUICKLY SAYING FIRST OF
ALL I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU.
TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT WE
CAN DO TO MAKE IT AS SIMPLE AS
POSSIBLE YOU KNOW.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO LIVE IN A
LITIGIOUS SOCIETY THAT REQUIRES
US TO ALWAYS PROTECT OURSELVES.
THIS WAS A FORM OF PROTECTION I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOCTORS WERE PROTECTED AND- YOU
KNOW WE WORKED WITH IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS WE'VE WORKED ON TO
VACCINATION RELATED BILLS.
WHICH CMA SPONSOR. AND THE
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF PAPERWORK
THAT'S ACTUALLY BEEN GENERATED
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
EVERYBODY ELSE INVOLVED IT'S
QUITE SIGNIFICANT AND THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT PAPERWORK
IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT WHEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE TO MAIL
OUT TO PARENTS. A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF ENORMOUS VOLUMES OF
LETTERS REQUIRING. A RESPONSE
BACK SO. WHATEVER YOU DO IN
THIS ARENA I THINK IN ORDER TO
PROTECT ONESELF THERE'S GONNA
BE A NEED FOR DOCUMENTING WELL
THAT'S JUST PART OF THE SOCIETY
WE LIVE IN. SO I THINK THAT
APPLIES TO ALL OF US AND I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU OKAY
WELL- I- I WOULD APPRECIATE. A
FIRM COMMITMENT THAT- SOME
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS WHICH
COULD BE TAKEN TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE WHICH STILL
ACHIEVE ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOUR
BILL IS SEEKING TO ACHIEVE
FILES REDUCING THOSE BURDENS. I
DO SEND SOME RELUCTANCE THERE
WHICH I'M A LITTLE DISTURBEDBY
I WOULD POINT OUT- SINCE YOU
MADE REFERENCE TO IT SP TWO
SEVEN SEVEN ACTUALLY DIDN'T GO
TO A PROTEST BECAUSE THERE WAS
NO COST. AS SOMETHING SCHOOLS
ALREADY HAD TO DO- BUT- I WOULD
JUST- YES I HOPE THAT YOU'D BE
WILLING TO AGAIN WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY I'M ACTUALLY ASKING
YOU TO CHANGE ANYTHING WE'RE
OBLIGATED TO DOCTORS TO DO. I
JUST WANTED TO REDUCE THE OVER
THE ADMINISTRATIVE. BURDENS ON
THE PRACTICE WHICH OF COURSE
RESULT IN HIGHER COSTS YOU KNOW
HEALTH CARE COSTS TO. BE MINOR
BUT AGAIN JUST CUMULATIVELY
SELF- YEAH I WANT TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL BUT I HOPE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD APPRECIATE THE
CHANGES YOU'VE MADE. I THINK
HIS FINAL ELEMENT OF- AGAIN
REDUCING THE ADDITIONAL MYSTERY
BURDEN WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL-
AND- I HOPE THAT YOU CAN COMMIT
TO THAT- WHEN DID. THIS BILL
COMES OUT OF COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. DR BEN THANK YOU YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT AND WHAT I WOULD
ALSO ASK. MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
DON'T MIND I'M HAPPY TO ENGAGE
WITH YOU AS WELL. EVEN SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD FROM
THIS COMMITTEE. FOR ALL OF US
TO WORK TOGETHER SO THAT SO
THAT ANY OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE.
GOING TO BE COMING UP NOW.
AGAIN SHOULD THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU MIKE MY GOAL IS FOR THIS
BILL TO RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE THAT'S THE-
FUNDAMENTAL KEY COMPONENTS SO.
WHATEVER WE CAN TO MEET THAT
OBJECTIVE. THE PHONE NUMBER
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR I THINK WHAT DR PANAS
ASKING. IS IF YOU WILL COMMIT
THAT FOR ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES
MAY PHYSICIAN. SIMPLY ATTEST
THAT THIS. DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENT WAS COMPLIED WITH.
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING TO
MAINTAIN. A PAPER OR ELECTRONIC
RECORDS. OF COVERING ANNUAL
DISCLOSURES TO HOWEVER MANY
PATIENTS THE PHYSICIAN SERVICES
SO. IT'S AN ATTESTATION I THINK
THAT HE'S ASKING FOR SO PERHAPS
YOU COULD. FURTHER ADDRESS THAT
IF YOU BELIEVE IT APPROPRIATE
IN YOUR CLOTHES. THANK YOU I
WILL. THANK YOU SENATOR PANZER
BACKER. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S DEDICATION AND
PASSION TO THIS ISSUE. THIS
BILL WILL DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
EXPOSURE TO THIS DATABASE AGAIN
JUST TWENTY VERY CLEAR SO THE
POSTING IN THE OFFICE WHICH IS
BAR ALL THAT'S REQUIRED FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD I BELIEVE-
HANDING TO THE PATIENT AND THE
PATIENT'S SIGNING THAT THEY'VE
RECEIVED THIS. THEN IT WOULD BE
VERY CLEAR YOU GET THIS FROM
EVERY DOCTOR YOU GO TO SHOW
EVERY SPECIALIST EVERY DOCTOR
YOU WILL GET ACCESS TO THE SAME
PAPER ABOUT THE SAME DATABASE
THAT'S LOTS OF EXPOSURE SO. I
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THE AUTHOR I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL WITH THE ANNUAL
REQUIREMENT I THINK THE BANG
FOR THE BUCK IT IS JUST NOT
THERE SO WHICH IS TO CLARIFY
WITH YOUR ROTH I THINK. WITHIN
A PEN WAS SAYING NOT JUST. THE
ATTESTATION ABOUT THE ANNUAL
DISCLOSURE BUT- THAT THE ANNUAL
DISCLOSURE ITSELF BE BE REMOVED
FROM THE BILL SO. IF YOU COMMIT
TO THAT I WILL SUPPORT IF NOT I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING IT HERE
TODAY. SERMON THANK YOU- I TOO
WAS A LITTLE UNCLEAR IN YOUR
INTERACTIONS WITH CENTER PAN IF
YOU WOULD COMMIT TO WORKING
WITH HIM- I WILL SUPPORT THIS
BILL PROVIDED THAT YOU DRESS IN
THE CONCERNS I THINK IF THERE
IS- YOU KNOW DISCLOSURES ALWAYS
WORTHWHILE AND EXPERIENCE YOU
DESCRIBED AS IT IS A TROUBLING
ONE- YOU KNOW MANY OF US GO
INTO OUR OFFICES OF ANY KIND
AND WE DON'T READ WHAT'S ON THE
WALLS YOU KNOW WE WERE ON OUR
PHONES WE JUST GO IN SO I
UNDERSTAND THE POINT OF THIS
BUT I THINK. THE OPPOSITION AND
A LOT OF DOCTORS IN MY
COMMUNITY HAVE RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ASSOCIATED WITH KEEPING
A LOT OF RECORDS ON FILE IN
PERPETUITY- SO IF YOU COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH DR CENTER PANEL ON
ON THIS ISSUE I CAN SUPPORT
THIS AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE ON THIS. ISSUE
THANK YOU. SERMON. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST ALSO WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR RIGHT BY-
CENTER BACKER HAS- FAIRLY WELL
ARTICULATED MY OWN POSITION-
AND SO FOR THE OTHER TWO JUST
TO BE VERY CLEAR- BASED ON THE
NUMBER CONVERSATION WE HAD I AM
EQUALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
IF IT CONTAINS AN EXPLICIT
AMENDMENT O REMOVE THE ANNUAL
INFORMATION REQUIREMENT- BUT IF
NOT AS I SAID I. UNDERSTAND THE
BILL. THANK YOU SIR JONES I
JUST WANTED TO- CHIME IN ON THE
SAME ISSUE AND I WISH I HAD
WHEN YOU CONTACT ME OR WE CAN I
SHOULD EXPLAIN THATTO YOU THAT
THAT WAS MY ONE CONCERN IS THE
ANNUAL NOTIFICATION SO I WAS%
GONNA VOTE NO TODAY I'LL LAY
OFF TODAY AND- ASIAN OF THE-
MOMENTUM THAT. WE HAVE HERE AND
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
THE NEXT COMMITTEE. WHAT DOES
NEED TO GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR IT TO BE
SUPPORTED IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE. SENATOR SO I DO HOPE
E. R. B. I DO HOPE YOU HAVE THE
TRUST IN ME TO BE ABLE TO WORK
ON IT. COLLINGS ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTER BACKERS AT YOUR
MICROPHONE MOVING UP. I GUESS
I'M JUST NOT CLEAR WHAT THE
COMMITMENT IS EXACTLY ARE YOU
GOING TO TAKE THAT OUT- I DON'T
REALLY SEE A MIDDLE GROUND IN
TERMS OF WORKING. TO ADDRESS
THAT THERE'S IF I MAY I'M HAPPY
TO I WAS JUST WAITING FOR ALL
THE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I'M HAPPY
TO RESPOND IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
MAY BE A STICKING POINT THIS
WAS ONE OF THE POINTS THAT CMA
HAD BROUGHT UP- AND SO I
SIGNIFICANTLY. CHANGE THE BILL
TOOK OUT A MAJOR COMPONENT THAT
WAS UNDERSTANDABLY THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLE I MYSELF SAW THE WHEN
YOU BURTON OFFICES BY HAVING TO
HAVE THEIR ASSISTANT GO THROUGH
THIS DOCUMENT THIS WEBSITE AND
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE BIGGEST
CONTRIBUTORS ARE AND WHETHER OR
NOT THAT CONTRIBUTION THE
CUMULATIVE NUMBER OF AMOUNTS OF
CONTRIBUTION- SURPASSES A
CERTAIN CERTAIN THRESHOLD OR
NOT I COULD UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH
WORK THAT CREATES THE I AND I
IN NO WAY INTENDED FOR TO
CREATE. OR BE SUCH A BIG BURDEN
OF NOW WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SIGNATURES COLLEAGUES LET'S
LET'S LET'S PLEASE BE FRANK
WITH ONE ANOTHER ALSO HOW MANY
TIMES DO WE GO TO A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE AND BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
BEEN THERE MAYBE IN A YEAR'S
TIME TWO YEARS TIME. BUT
SOMETHING ABOUT THE INSURANCE
DOCUMENTATION HAS CHANGED THE
INSURANCE COMPANY HAS CHANGED
EVERY THREE YEARS WERE REQUIRED
TO SIGN THE DOCUMENTS- YOU KNOW
I JUST SHOWED UP TO MY- MY
ORTHOPEDIC SURGEON'S OFFICE
AND- I NEEDED TO FILL OUT. ALL
SEVEN PAGES OF DOCUMENTATION OF
WHAT FAMILY ISSUES I'VE HAD IN
THE PAST BECAUSE SOME OF THOSE
THINGS MAY HAVE CHANGED OVER
THE COURSE OF THE SEVEN YEARS
THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN THERE. I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
ALLERGIES MIGHT DEVELOP. SO TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION. I THINK
THAT MR BECKER THERE IS A
MIDDLE GROUND AS AS WE WERE
TALKING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE WEEKEND-
I SEE IT AS SOMETHING WHERE.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE ANNUAL
OUT AS I SAID THIS TO YOU AS
WELL OVER THE WEEKEND ON IT'S
JUST IT'S COMING IN SO LATE
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO.
COMMIT TO YOU TO SOMETHING-
BECAUSE IT FORCES ME INTO A
REVOKE HERBAL POSITION IF I DO
SO BUT AS I SAID TO YOU OVER
THE PHONE I AM HAPPY. TO WORK
WITH YOU ON COMING UP WITH A
THREE YEAR TIMELINE SIMMONS
HIP- WHEN YOU FILL OUT THE
HIPPA DOCUMENTS. WHY NOT ATTACH
THIS FORM. SO ON OR WHAT.
PLEASE OFFER SOME OTHER
SUGGESTIONS I AM HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU. AND AGAIN IF THE IF
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO BE
INVOLVED I WOULD ASK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO BE INVOLVED WITH THIS
IN THIS DIALOGUE AS WELL. I'M
HAPPY TO ACCOMMODATE THE ONLY
THING IS THAT I THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME LEVEL OF
FREQUENCY. BECAUSE AS MUCH AS
I. I DO AGREE WITH ME. MR
BECKER ABOUT CENTER BECKER
ABOUT THE FACT THAT- SOME SOME
PATIENTS HAVE MULTIPLE DOCTORS
YOU'RE COMPLETELY ACCURATE
ABOUT THAT. BUT IT'S ALSO A
DEMOGRAPHIC ISSUE. I RIGHT NOW
ONLY NEED MAYBE ONE OR TWO
DOCTORS I KNOW IN ABOUT TEN
YEARS TIME. I PROBABLY FULL FEE
FOUR OR FIVE DIFFERENT DOCTORS
SO I DO UNDERSTAND THAT
EXPOSURE ARGUMENT- I JUST FEEL
LIKE IN ORDER TO CAPTURE SOME
OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS THAT ARE
SENSITIVE THAT MIGHT NOT BE. AS
EXPOSED WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF A MIDDLE GROUND SO I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU. I I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU.
I JUST CAN'T SEE I CAN CONFIRM
THAT WE TAKE THAT OUT BECAUSE
IF I DO- THERE'S NO POINT OF
RETURN AT THAT POINT BUT I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ACCOMMODATE CHANGING.
I EVEN OFFERED TO CHANGE IT
BASED ON IT BUT- I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE THAT AMENDMENT RIGHT NOW-
BUT- BUT OTHERWISE- AGAIN YOU
HAVE MY FIRM COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU.
ALREADY SUMMER MEMBER I THINK
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE ASKING
FOR IS SOME. SOME CERTAINTY.
WITH REGARD TO THE COMMITMENTS.
SO IF I'M UNDERSTANDING YOU
CORRECTLY YOU COMMITTED. TO
CHANGING. THE ANNUAL
REQUIREMENT IF NOT DELETING IT
DID I HEAR YOU SAY CHANGES I
DID NOT SEE DELETE I DID SAY I
AM HAPPY TO CHANGE IT. AND I'M
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT. THAT THAT
MIDDLE GROUND IS. TO MAKE IT TO
MAKE IT LESS FREQUENT NOT MORE
FREQUENT EXACTLY AND DID I
UNDERSTAND YOU TO COMMIT TO.
CHANGING THE RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENT TO SOMETHING AKIN
TO WHAT SENATOR PAN WAS TALKING
ABOUT WITH WHICH IS A-
PHYSICIAN AT THE STATION. YES
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT AS WELL. BECAUSE OF COURSE.
COLLEAGUES MAKE DECISIONS ON
WHETHER THEY VOTE YES OR NO OR
VOTE AT ALL BASED ON WHAT
OFFICERS COMMIT TO DO IT OF
COURSE ONCE AUTHORS LEAVE THIS
COMMITTEE THEN THERE ARE WAYS
FOR US TO YOU KNOW DEAL WITH
BILLS WHERE THE COMMITMENTS
HAVEN'T BEEN MADE I'M JUST
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR HERE SENATOR HERTEL
THOUGH DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION
COMMENT OR CONCERN. JUST A
QUICK COMMENT OF MR CHAIR
APPOINTED TO THAT YOU THINK.
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I KNOW WHEN I
FIRST TOOK A LOOK AT IT. I HAD
A DIFFICULT TIME TRYING TO
SUPPORT IT AND- BUT AT THE SAME
TIME I ALSO REALLY HAVE MUCH
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE. THAT THE
PASSION AND THE EFFORT THAT
HE'S PUTTING IN TO TRY TO.
PROTECT PATIENTS A BIT OF HIS
OF HIS DISTRICT- AND I CAN.
REALLY IDENTIFY WITH THAT AS
WELL- AND I KNOW THAT THE BILL
IS NOT PERFECT THAT NEEDS SOME
WORK. BUT I THINK IT DESERVES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD- DETER STOLE SEVERAL
HURDLES THAT- HE'LL HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO GO THROUGH TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS BILL ULTIMATELY
GET SIGNED AND PASSED AND- YOU
KNOW AS I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH HIM OVER THE WEEKEND I
DON'T THINK THAT. EUROPE ALL
THE GOOD DOCTORS OUT THERE
SHOULD BE PUNISHED FOR THE FIVE
VERY FEW BAD ONES THAT ARE OUT
THERE BUT- AHA AS I. MENTIONED
EARLIER I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS THAT HE'S PUT INTO THIS
AND- HAPPY TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER NEWMAN.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SERVIC I DO APPRECIATE. WHAT
THE AUTHOR SET OUT TO DO- BUT I
WANT TO BE CLEAR HERE AS I
THINK I'M LISTENING ON THE GO
SPEAK FOR MORE THAN JUST
MYSELF- AND SO. I'M LOOKING-
YOU PROBABLY HAVE A VOTE COUNT-
BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU MY VOTE
COUNTS MY PERSONAL ACCOUNT I AM
LOOKING FOR AN EXPLICIT
COMMITMENT. FOR THE REMOVAL OF
THE ANNUAL REQUIREMENT- TO
APPRISE PATIENTS- AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO PROVIDE A COMMITMENT-
BUT IF NOT- I WANNA MAKE VERY
CLEAR THAT I WILL BE STAYING UP
THIS BILL TODAY. WELL WHEN I
MET YOU DON'T WE DON'T
NEGOTIATE. AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SO
YOU CAN PROVIDE WHATEVER
COMMITMENT SURE. ABLE TO
PROVIDE IN RESPONSE TO MY
COLLEAGUE'S QUESTIONS AND THEN-
THEY WILL- THEY WILL DECIDE
ACCORDINGLY. I SEE NO OTHER
MIKES UP SO- THERE'S TWO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR HER TITLE. SO YOU ARE
FREE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR I DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE TO COMMIT TO I DON'T KNOW
IF MY FIRSTBORN IS GONNA BE
ENOUGH AT THIS POINT- MISTER
NEWMAN I RESPECT YOU VERY MUCH
AND I APPRECIATE WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM BUT- WENDY CAN BE
YOUR MOTHER. COULD BE YOUR
SPOUSE COULD BE YOUR SISTER.
THIS BILL IS NOT A SPONSORED
BILL THIS BILL WAS THE AGONY OF
A CONSTITUENT. WHO TOOK THE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES HAVE A
DOUBLE MASTECTOMY IN ORDER TO
PROTECT HERSELF SOMETHING WE
TEACH SOMETHING ARE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TEACH. SHE TOOK
THAT STEP. AND THEN SHE WENT IN
FOR RECONSTRUCTIVE SURGERY AND
HAS BEEN PAYING THE PRICE FOR
IT SINCE IT COULD BE ANY OF OUR-
THE WIND LOVED WOMEN IN OUR
LIVES- I MEAN WE BOTH ARE ALSO
PART OF A CAUCUS THAT TALKS
ABOUT TIKKUN OLAM SO I'M JUST
TRYING THIS IS MY SMALL WAY. OF
REPAIRING THE WORLD- I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE ON THE MEDICAL BOARD. SO
THAT PHYSICIANS WHO COMMIT
ATROCIOUS ACTS LIKE THIS AREN'T
JUST FIND A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
GIVEN THE PAIN AND SUFFERING
WHEN HE HAS GONE THROUGH THIS
POSITION WAS ONLY HELD LIABLE
TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS. EIGHT
SOMETHING THAT REVEALS AND
ALLOWS EVERYONE TO KNOW FURTHER
CREATES ACCOUNTABILITY AND IT'S
A GOOD THING. WE DON'T HAVE
CLOAKED PROBLEMS WITH OUR
DISCLOSURES THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO ABIDE BY. THE MORE
DISCLOSURE THE BETTER IT IS SO-
FOLKS THE OTHER THING I WANTED
TO MENTION IS THAT DIRECTOR OR
EDUCATING THERE'S THREE EASE
AND GOVERNMENT THAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT THIS EDUCATING
THERE'S ENGINEERING AND THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT. ENGINEERING AND
ENFORCEMENT ARE REALLY COSTLY
EDUCATING IS THE BEST WAY. AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I FIND IT
SOMEWHAT INTERESTING THAT- YOU
KNOW THAT THIS BILL WENT
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY I HAVE TWO
DOCTORS IN MY HOUSE DR CULA
WEBER AND DOCTOR OF LOOKING
AROUND BILA. WHO VOTED FOR THIS
BILL I DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
COME FROM THEM. IN FACT ONE OF
THEM VOTED TWICE BECAUSE IT
CAME UP IN A COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS ON THE FLOOR- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT COMMITMENT YOU ARE LOOKING
FOR. BUT I AM HAPPY TO. MAKE
THE CHANGES NECESSARY. AND I
DON'T KNOW OF RIGHT NOW I'M
BEING HEARD OR NOT BUT I'M
HAPPY TO MAKE THE CHANGES
NECESSARY. TO WIN YOUR SUPPORT
BUT I CAN'T COMMIT TO JUST
TAKING SOMETHING OUT RIGHT NOW.
AND THEN NOT BEING ABLE TO
DISCUSS IT AND AGAIN AS I ASKED
IF THE CHECK IF THE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO BE INVOLVED IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS. I'M HAPPY TO
STICK BY MY COMMITMENT AND SEE
HOW WE CAN MEET HALFWAY OR
MAYBE EVEN 60% 70% YOUR WEIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH MORE OF A
COMMITMENT I CAN GIVE AT THIS
POINT BUT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
SUPPORT IT SIR. IT'S OBVIOUSLY
YOUR PREROGATIVE HE'S CLOSING.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SERMON
WE JUST HAD THE CLOSES OR
SOMETHING. OKAY THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS CLOSED WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL BY SENATOR
TAYO. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHTY PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED ONLY
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH HEY RALPH
EYED BELINDA'S ARCHULETA.
CHILLOUT ICE BEATS HOLDING
BECKER. DAUGHTER BY DOT HI
ADNAN HEY MAN I HER TADO HI
FURTADO I JONES. LEVI HI LEAVE
ICEMEN MAN HI NEWMAN. A SHOW
ABOUT OKAY NOT VOTING. PIANO
CAN I. BILL IS EIGHTY VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN UNTIL
WE CLOSE OUT THANK YOU A SEVEN
MEMBER THANK YOU MR CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE REMEMBER
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
START WITH- ITEM NUMBER ONE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FIVE. NINE FILE ITEM
ONE A. B. THREE FIVE NINE
CURRENT VOTE NINE TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I BEATS
BEATS BY HER TADO HER TADO I'D
NEWMAN. MR NEWMAN I. NEWMAN I.
LLEVA LEAVE A I. BILL BILL AS
FOURTEEN VOTES THAT MATTER IS
BILL IS OUT. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD A. B. FIVE TWO SIX
BY LATE IN FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
TO SIX CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
IBEATS. BEATS HI LLEVA LEAVE A
HI NEWMAN NEW MAY NOT A BILL
HAS FOURTEEN VOTES THAT MATTER
IS OUT. FIVE ITEM THREE AB TEN
SIXTY FOUR CURRENT VOTE NINETY
ZERO ARCHULETA. B. BEATS HI
LISA LEAVE BY NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
HE N. TWELVE ZERO THE MATTER IS
A- OUR. THIS IS WHAT ONE DOES
I'M SORRY I MUST HAVE WRITTEN
R. GILLETTE AND WHO DOES I
APOLOGIZE I AM FILE IT IN THREE
EIGHTY TEN SIXTY FOUR MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I THIRTEEN ZERO THE
LETTERS OF. FOLLOWING HIM FOR
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. B. BAIT NO JONES
JONES II LLEVA MAN. HANNAH.
NINETY ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FIVE EIGHT AND SIX EIGHTY
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR CURRENT VOTE
ELEVEN TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I A MAN A MAN I JONES
JONES I. HER BOOK FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT MATTER IS OUT. FAIL ITEMS.
SEVEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S. THIRTEEN ZERO
THAT MATTER IS OUT. FILE ITEM
EIGHT AB FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. HER TADO HER TADO II.
KERBAL THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
MATTERS OUT. FILE ITEM. NINE
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE
CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I BEATS.
HER TADO HER TADO HI A CHILL
ABODE. VOTE TWELVE ZERO THAT
MATTERS OUT. FILE ITEM. TEN
EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I HER TADO
HER TADO II REMOVED FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT MATTERS OUT. FILE
ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
THIRTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ I VOTE FOURTEEN ZERO
THAT MATTERS OF. FILE ITEM
TWELVE EIGHTY FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TO ZERO
MELINDA'S. LENDERS IBEATS.
BEEPS I HEARD VOTE FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT MATTERS OUT. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS FEW
AND FIVE CURRENT BOAT TWELVE TO
ZERO MELINDA'S MELENDEZ IBEATS.
EIGHT I HEARD VOTE FOURTEEN
ZERO THAT MATTERS A- FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE NINETY
TWO CURRENT VOTE TWELVE TWO
ZERO MELINDA'S. LENDERS IBEATS
BAIT I WROTE FOURTEEN ZERO THAT
MATTERS A. FILE IN FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. BEATS BACKER. JONES
NEW MAN. A SHOW ABOUT- VOTE
EIGHT ZERO THAT MATTER IS OUT.
BUT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
TODAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY.
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE INCLUDE
THEM IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS.
WEAGAIN APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. IS A JERK.